[SPEAKER_03]: This is Calder.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hello, I'm Felix.
[SPEAKER_00]: Crimson, you're not paying attention.
[SPEAKER_02]: What?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't need to do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm everyone else.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have a character name.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm all the other characters.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, it does know who I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, you guys living in the city of Pavo, it is the year 756.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is day two of the tide, the winter month.
[SPEAKER_02]: And on Harvest Fest, the end of the previous autumn month, you were all at Oblong Square between the core and the stacks where you witnessed the murder of Theo Blackwood.
[SPEAKER_02]: And all of you decided to stick around whilst everybody else ran away in fear of the violence that they saw.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rest of you decided to stick around because you were all connected in some way to this, to Theo, a sort of local politician and guild
[SPEAKER_02]: up-and-coming guild politician in the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was shot from a distance, this much you guys were able to discern, and the shot seemed to basically kill him instantly, rushing over to him.
[SPEAKER_02]: You weren't even able to revive him or bring him back with any kind of healing magics, even though you tried.
[SPEAKER_02]: And in the aftermath, the Guild of Engineers turned up and had a confrontation with you guys which resulted in you killing one of their sergeants and fleeing back to the Plum and Bob, the tavern on the square here run by Harle, where Esker interrogated the group and tried to work out why everybody was interested in Theo and why exactly everybody decided to help out.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys parted ways and headed off to basically run any leads that you could, find out any information you could about Theo and the attempted assassination.
[SPEAKER_02]: And over the next couple of days, you headed into your various directions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Some of you interacting with your jobs.
[SPEAKER_02]: Some of you, such as Felix, getting fired from the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Other people voluntarily leaving their jobs, intending to track down this lead instead.
[SPEAKER_02]: But after you've all
[SPEAKER_02]: headed throughout these various leads etc you brought your information back to the Plum and Bob on the second day in the evening.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the back room of the Plum and Bob you guys discussed what you'd found out you discussed a little bit more about each other's backstories and who exactly you were and
[SPEAKER_02]: some of you more open than others, but you gain some information and you notice that there was a previous acquaintance of Theo in the bar that Lark was sent to interrogate about his potential knowledge of Theo and what might happen now.
[SPEAKER_02]: In doing so, Lark discovered that
[SPEAKER_02]: Theo had had an argument recently with two dangerous-looking sorts, and at that very moment, those dangerous-looking sorts indeed arrived at the tavern, pushed their way in, and made a declaration looking for anyone who was associated with Theo.
[SPEAKER_02]: You failed to lie that you didn't know anything about it, and Lark kind of decided to
[SPEAKER_02]: take this outside, although I don't think in a violent way, but you headed outside with one of these two thugs whilst the other one stayed inside.
[SPEAKER_02]: Outside, this large woman in a green overcoat that you recognise to be from the Porters Guild pinned you up against a wall and basically attempted to shake you down for information about Theo's contacts.
[SPEAKER_02]: specifically asking you about the type of business that he was in, and if you knew any people that he worked with, which didn't mean a lot to you, and you truthfully said that you didn't know, but she didn't believe you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did manage to expertly wriggle out of her grasp and set off running down Oblong Square.
[SPEAKER_02]: There are people around in the square here, despite the image, and you head off down Oblong Square and attempted to escape.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, the rest of the group bar Billiom snuck out of the back, using pass without a trace from Felix, to sneak your way around through the alleyways at the back of the tavern and are basically about to arrive at Oblong Square at the same time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, Billiom stayed inside and kind of got a little bit turned around by heading into the main room and then heading back into the back room and then realizing that everybody else had left.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Billy, you are alone in the back room, all of your friends having left.
[SPEAKER_02]: The rest of the party are outside in the alleyway, and Lark is running away screaming I don't know any names, as this woman is attempting to teach us.
[SPEAKER_02]: Screamed it once.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know why the transcript said I did it multiple times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Screaming it once or screaming it multiple times.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, that doesn't work.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me do this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just put the art for both these characters up here.
[SPEAKER_02]: don't need your art necessarily at the moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think we finished with basically deciding that we were going to roll initiative here because I think danger is afoot, although you're not sure exactly to what extent, but it's a good time to roll some initiative.
[SPEAKER_02]: So let me add some turns for you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have solved this in other
[SPEAKER_03]: Sheets, but in this sheet, ideally, you still have to manually add all of your turns, which means...
[SPEAKER_03]: I like that roll number 16.60.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if someone rolls a 16, I'm higher up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, did I select my character?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you have to manually input it, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you do on this sheet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Terrible roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, I'm just going to run down.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tell me what you got, Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: 16.16.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm not going to put point 16.
[SPEAKER_05]: He got six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't see the chat and write in here at the same time.
[SPEAKER_06]: I called it.
[SPEAKER_06]: 13.
[SPEAKER_06]: Billy, four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: And luck.
[SPEAKER_01]: I got 18.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, you got mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Someone just gave me it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: I didn't say Billy's role, but.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, you wrote that to me, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think because you was testing something out before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, oh.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And let me do this and cool and cool and cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So initiative from the top then here, it is actually the ASMR who is standing inside the bar, the ailer, standing inside the bar on the inside of the door, which none of you see given that Billy is in the back room.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think he just opens the door up actually and reenters the square behind the woman.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's about 10 feet behind the large woman and he looks at Lark running away.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's all he can see.
[SPEAKER_02]: And again, there is multiple traders here.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like packed.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not festival level of
[SPEAKER_02]: citizens walking around here but it is definitely like busy enough that you can potentially slip into the crowd and try and hide if you're attempting to escape in that there in that way however it's his turn first and he sees you and he will um
[SPEAKER_02]: I think he's just going to rush directly at you, seeing that you are running away.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is going to expend a focus point to a step of the wind and double his movement speed.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you say last time that the lady just like stopped?
[SPEAKER_00]: She didn't go after me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, she didn't initially chase after you.
[SPEAKER_02]: She stayed where she was.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this guy easily overtakes her and is basically going to chase you.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's your base movement speed like?
[SPEAKER_00]: 30.
[SPEAKER_02]: 30.
[SPEAKER_02]: In which case, with double his movement speed, he is easily going to catch up to you from the door here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he is going to attack you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you used some bonus action?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he used Step of the Wind that allows him to dash as a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a monk.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he rushes up to you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, monk spoilers!
[SPEAKER_01]: Yo!
[SPEAKER_02]: Boilers.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't roll that, but he rolled a 20 to hit you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was a whisper.
[SPEAKER_02]: He does two points of bludgeoning damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think that's correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's not correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's to be in love more.
[SPEAKER_02]: His monk.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a terrible monk.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know why that's not working.
[SPEAKER_00]: I forgot what my character does.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why didn't I go through my sheet before?
[SPEAKER_02]: He does 10 points of bludgeoning damage to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But more importantly, you need to make a constitution saving throw for me, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: More important than 10 damage?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, more important than 10 damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a four, you are stunned as he stunning strikes the back of your head.
[SPEAKER_02]: This sounds familiar.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hold on, maybe I can do something once I figure out my character.
[SPEAKER_03]: Reactions.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess I'm stunned.
[SPEAKER_03]: And of course my turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so unfortunately you are stunned, which... Do I just drop down?
[SPEAKER_02]: He bonks me in the back of my head and I just... No, so stunned is...
[SPEAKER_02]: Your movement speed is zero.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, you can run when we were having this discussion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Stunned is weird in this game compared to what you might think from other video games.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can still move when you're stunned.
[SPEAKER_02]: People just have an advantage against you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Stunning Strike might be different.
[SPEAKER_01]: Stunned with Stunning Strike, they can't move either.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's speed becomes zero, cannot move.
[SPEAKER_00]: When you're stunned, you become incapacitated and immobile.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yeah, you're incapacitated and you automatically fail strength and dexterity throws and attack rolls against you have advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it is your turn now.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he rushes past at speed and just, yeah, just like one fist to the back of your head as you are running away and instantly knocks you like... Where are we?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we in the middle of a crowd?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were in the middle of a bunch of merchants sort of turn and look and are like, what the fuck is going on?
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, he seems to be- This man is beating a kid.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would shout if you weren't incapacitated.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't take action for reactions.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, yeah, pretty much you can't do anything here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't do anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're just fucked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're just there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Felix, from your position, along with the other three, you guys are down about a 20 foot alleyway off the square itself.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think you heard Lark shouting as you guys came around the corner.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're within range to hear that, but you don't see anything because you guys are still down the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's your turn to do what you want here, but you don't know exactly what's going on.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll go to the end of the other way and just sneak around the corner to see what's happening and where everybody is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you use 20 feet of movement, you can see I think there's enough of a commotion that the
[SPEAKER_02]: The crowd has parted a little bit and backed off a little bit from where there's clearly a fight going on, so you can see that happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think there's not that many people that you can't see through the crowd.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make out this A-list standing over the top of Lark, who has clearly just taken a hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: How far away is it?
[SPEAKER_03]: From where you are, it's probably like another 20 feet from where you are.
[SPEAKER_03]: I am going to cast Hold Person on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK, I will make you make a stealth check.
[SPEAKER_02]: You still have a password and a trace?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: To see whether anyone is able to react to this or whether you are doing it completely unnoticed.
[SPEAKER_02]: it is the first one yes in your haste to sort of like push your way out of the alleyway you kind of knock a few barrels and bits of things over and there's a bit of a commotion in the alleyway entrance which means that she's gonna look towards you the woman and counter spell your whole person so you have to
[SPEAKER_02]: Make a check now, can spell is different than it was.
[SPEAKER_02]: You also don't lose, if you fail, you don't lose the, you don't lose the spell slot anymore either.
[SPEAKER_03]: But do I have to roll?
[SPEAKER_03]: I think it's constitution, let me check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you make a constitution saving throw.
[SPEAKER_02]: With a five, unfortunately, you fail.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yeah, so unlike previous counter spell, you don't lose the.
[SPEAKER_02]: You lose the spell slot, but you don't cast the spell either.
[SPEAKER_02]: You do lose the action that cost you to cast it as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you still have a bonus action if you want to do anything else.
[SPEAKER_03]: I realize the music is way too chill for this.
[SPEAKER_00]: We don't feel the sense of urgency here.
Not yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, anything with your bonus action, Felix?
[SPEAKER_03]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: No?
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Cole, you're 20 feet back.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see Felix rush forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see him attempt to cast a spell or something like that as he arrives at the square.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I will be walking over there and I cast Mage Armor on myself.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I shout, these people are beating up innocent person.
[SPEAKER_06]: Somebody help.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a persuasion check for the crowd in general.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, if I remember where that is.
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah oh hell yeah oh that's actually a good one you get the attention of some of the people who are walking past you see there's a merchant pulling a cart there's a couple of washer women with like laundry baskets who are coming back from the
[SPEAKER_02]: the laundry they kind of look towards you and they're kind of a little confused about what is happening you can see that they sort of clock there's a fight happening at least between a guy and who's just punched a girl in the back of the head but they don't immediately react to kind of get themselves involved in it but you're starting to cause a bit of a commotion and people are focusing towards what is happening you can also make an insight check hold it
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't really read the Ayla at all, the guy who is like on top of Lark at the moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you notice that there's a little twitch, I think, in the expression of the woman in green at the back, as she kind of like does that thing where she's looking around like, oh, there's a, there's a few people like this is kind of public, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like she, you know, as you shout that, you see her react to that as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I keep walking walking towards Lark, maybe staying like 10 feet away or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you use your full movement, you'll be 10 foot away from from where they are at the moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: You kind of push your way past the car and around to look at what's happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: The woman in Green's turn, then she is looking around here.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see she looks a little.
[SPEAKER_03]: A little wary about the fact that there are people around here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, your movement was 30 feet, right, Lak?
[SPEAKER_03]: So you're 30 feet away from her.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Crimson, I did dash.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did.
[SPEAKER_02]: You did, actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you are 60 feet away from her.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What will she do?
[SPEAKER_02]: She's going to move 30 feet towards you.
[SPEAKER_02]: She stays 30 feet out of range of you.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think that's it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: She rushes forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: She gets sort of backing up her friend, but she is not going to do anything over at the moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, ask it or ask her same thing for you in the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see these two guys rush forward and clearly something's happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to, uh, because they're still within 60 feet of me, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have to get line of sight on them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: They are within 60 feet of you, but if you need line of sight for something, then you still have to.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I'm going to activate radiant course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I want to put it in the chat.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hold on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, I apparently did a check.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I, I activate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: How do I put it into the chat?
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to put it in the chat.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, not again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I think that's my mistake with setting up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think I set it up as an attack instead of a spell.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's just rolling dice for no reason because you don't need to roll for it.
[SPEAKER_02]: They roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I was going to say.
[SPEAKER_02]: With this, yeah, with this, it's any creature of your choice within 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you don't know the situation in the square.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to let you do it if you want to, but it's going to hit everybody.
[SPEAKER_02]: So including your allies, including the people in the because you're doing this from blind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, you can't see around the corner.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't see older.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess you can make you can avoid Felix because you can see Felix, but you're going to have to do just like a blind chorus thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't you can't pick out who exactly to aim it at with no website.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then then I'll then I'll go get line of sight first before I do it because I could because they're they're in the same area, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: So I kind of know where they are
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, you can just follow the alley down on the square as well next to Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's perfectly fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, then I'll just get line of sight.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah, I will use it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're just picking the two.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what is it Christmas saving throw?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, this guy is Christmas is not that great.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a 15.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a pizza and she's rolling a 13.
[SPEAKER_02]: I whispered that to myself by accident.
[SPEAKER_02]: But so she fails, he succeeds.
[SPEAKER_02]: So she is incapacitated, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Until the start of your next turn, which is huge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you guys watch who anyone who can see her just sees her like rush forward as if she's about to help out with help this ailer to deal with luck.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then she suddenly kind of stops and kind of looks up as if she's hearing music coming through that you guys don't you guys just hear like a chord coming out from the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: But she seems to like hear this beautiful song that is just keeping her where she is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ask a bone section or something.
[SPEAKER_01]: See.
[SPEAKER_01]: Does particle inspiration requires touch or is it?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's anyone you can.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think they can hear you, I think, if you're going to play a song or say inspiring words.
[SPEAKER_01]: While I'm playing the Radiant Chorus, I'm going to add an extra flourish into it towards Lark to inspire her.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you're doing the Radiant Chorus, what kind of song are you playing?
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the theme?
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the genre?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's like some soothing music to calm people down, to make them stop and
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, focus on the music exactly like the lady did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure, a little bit like Pied Piper.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, this beautiful music starts to play in the background, which you guys don't focus on too much.
[SPEAKER_02]: But this woman seems very enticed by it and like you feel inspired by this music as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, inside the back room, you hear
[SPEAKER_02]: Eska's music coming from the alleyway outside.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you probably heard the shouting coming from the front of the building by Lark just before this as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, so then since I didn't really see them go outside in the back door, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: So I wouldn't really know where they went anyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'm going to say I'm going to head back to the front door and go out from there and see whatever's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you rush through the patrons in the bar, or looking a little confused, looking around, wondering, do they need to help?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do they need to bar the door?
[SPEAKER_02]: What's happening?
[SPEAKER_02]: But you get to the front door, open it up, and see the same scene, Lark stunned.
[SPEAKER_02]: This woman appears to be stunned, or at least distracted.
[SPEAKER_05]: The guy that stunned Lark is probably standing right next to her then, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, right behind her, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, that's not good.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, then I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_05]: It's probably...
[SPEAKER_05]: He dashed, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: So I'd have to do a dash thing too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he dashed and he's got a lot of movement because he's a monk as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he's... From where you are, probably it's at least 60 feet, maybe like 70 feet.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll just dash for now and see how far I can get.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you can probably do another 30 feet, like moving through the bar through the patrons, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you use your dash, you get another 30 feet, which brings you basically up into melee with this woman, if you want to do that.
[SPEAKER_05]: She's focused on getting to work, I think, and kind of deal with that deal with that man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to just ignore her and you'll basically end up alongside her.
[SPEAKER_02]: She seems distracted and not participating right now, but you'll end up like right next to her basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: um okay the uh ala then is gonna look at you like he did 10 points of damage to you do you look injured after that like how is luck looking no no you look fine i should say yes so he doesn't fuck you up more um no
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, in which case he pulls off his belt a length of rope which he wraps around your neck and he will use his...
[SPEAKER_02]: attack on you, which is a 20, which is going to slow you and also does an additional 18 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he loops this rope.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you're stunned, so he should have had advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just in case he crits, we'll roll advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: He loops this rope around your neck and he's basically going to like use it to drag you backwards or that's his intention, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: It does damage anyway just because it's his weapon which is a vicious whip that is re-skinned.
[SPEAKER_02]: now she's looking hurt she's looking so hurt now sure um but yeah you can this guy is like you kind of look up in your like stunned state and you're also like choking you look over your back shoulder this guy is like emotionless he is just like doing a job here and he just like wraps this around your neck and he's basically like gonna try and use it to drag you backwards in a way seemingly not really caring if you uh survive the the
[SPEAKER_02]: um the attempt um but he can't do that on this turn he needs to like grapple you or something so that's just going to be his attack um and yeah so he's now just like standing over the top of you however you are no longer stunned yeah oh well i get the fear of death suddenly because like he takes every breath out of me with that strangling and
[SPEAKER_00]: Before I even do anything, I just go like, are you going to kill me just for a name?
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks straight in your eyes and says nothing.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can make a perception check.
Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were desperately trying to make out anything on his face, but you can't make out anything helpful in this situation.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your vision is going white and blacking out every now and again from the situation you're in.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're struggling to get anything coherent right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, my plans changed because you just took a chunk out of me.
[SPEAKER_00]: First, I use my second wind to heal.
[SPEAKER_00]: basically holding to my neck trying to get the whip out and getting some heal to myself.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I heal eight points.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: That bonus action.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, it is a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_00]: And so has he grappled me?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, technically by the rules, no, but basically, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, there is no way you are not considered grappled if he has a rope around your neck, but he didn't go through the motions to do it mechanically.
[SPEAKER_02]: But for this, for the purposes of this, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, because I was stunned.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it makes sense.
[SPEAKER_00]: He could do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
I
[SPEAKER_00]: Lark tries to get away.
[SPEAKER_00]: She tries to rip the whip out and get away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I just...
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think I can do disengage.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have to contest the... No, yeah, you will have to use your action for a strength check to try and escape.
[SPEAKER_00]: No!
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it need to be a strength check?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, tell me what you're trying to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well...
[SPEAKER_00]: There's certainly some self-defense moves where you can try to pull a thing out of your neck with some cool hand-twist movements that Lark should know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, but would Lark know those self-defense moves?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because she has taught self-defense.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the type of self-defense you were doing was probably like using a staff and hitting targets and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: You didn't really do like the martial arts.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, if you can think of a creative way in which you could use like acrobatics or something like that for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I try to keep
[SPEAKER_00]: his knee so that he would lose the balance and basically release the grip.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you want to basically use decks for that, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah that's what you're trying to do yes in which case i because your attacks are dex based i will let you do that as a dex save instead of uh strength save because you're basically doing your dexterity attacks to knock him off balance you're not doing damage you're just trying to break out of the grapple um and we'll say that yeah you kind of like push yourself off his his legs and kind of twist in a more acrobatic way so yeah you can do that um contesting
[SPEAKER_02]: with his strength it's not contested you need to beat his uh dc which is going to be eight plus his proficiency plus his strength uh which is uh i mean you don't have to tell me yeah well yeah yeah okay guys wish me luck i'm gonna click the button
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you managed to kind of like serpentine and kind of push us off around to do like a bit of one of those sort of judo flip type of situations where you end up uncoiled by the rope and you manage to break out of the thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, if you want to run away, you're going to take an opportunity attack, but you are no longer grappled.
[SPEAKER_00]: That was my action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I only have movement left.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I would move.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I want to move, and that's what I would do, even though I would take an opportunity attack, because I would just take multiple if I stay in melee.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I will just do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's going to make an opportunity attack on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: This time it's set up correctly.
[SPEAKER_02]: 14 to hit you.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: OK.
[SPEAKER_00]: I managed to run.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: trying to stumble through the crowd towards any alleyway away from him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so you can see that Calder is only 10 feet away from you, and 20 feet away from you at the entrance to the alleyway is Felix.
[SPEAKER_00]: How are they in front of me when I'm running away from the club?
[SPEAKER_02]: They went around the back.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they're basically right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, just distance-wise, this is just representative, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: But they basically went around the back, and you're like, you ran this way, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll take it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just, yeah, I'll go to that direction, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, towards the alleyway?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you have 30 feet of movement, you can make it to the alleyway from where you are.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you basically like barge into Felix and Eska who were at the entrance of the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
[SPEAKER_02]: You could either go into the alleyway or you can go further down the square like this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I get it now, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're aiming to go into the crowd and away from them, but you're sort of running past them and they see you and you see them, so everyone knows where everybody is.
[SPEAKER_00]: I see them, but I don't want them to get caught.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you see Lark manages to slip out of this and run off, but it's your turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: I am going to cast Hold Person again.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, she is still, or she's incapacitated, so she can't do anything about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he is going to make, geez, these guys are rolling so great.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you mean not rolling so great?
[SPEAKER_01]: You just hit Julie twice.
[SPEAKER_01]: You just hit Lara twice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, you know, I rolled an eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyway, he is held.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he is paralyzed.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he kind of yeah, he looks like he is about to start running after Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as he starts to move, he just kind of like freezes in place mids, like, taking his first step towards Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think in the last second, his eyes sort of dart towards you, Felix, as he sort of freezes in place, and he ends up looking directly at you as you cast the spell on him.
[SPEAKER_03]: We can run now.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lark, come here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, did you say something to me?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, come here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lark.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, she glances back and turns to them, realizing like he's enchanted.
[SPEAKER_00]: So she changes direction and runs to them then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: When it's your turn, if everything is still the same.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, you know now, you see that he has been like held up for a turn here as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Kolde, yeah, you're 10 feet away from him as he freezes in place here, and you see that Lark has escaped.
[SPEAKER_04]: Look at my bonus action.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, go for your bonus action.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to cast Healing Words on Lark.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Healing word, healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seven points of healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Healing word, healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Wait, can you do multiple leveled spells?
[SPEAKER_02]: Ah, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: Isn't holding person.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can only do a cantrip with your bonus if you have a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sorry, Lark.
[SPEAKER_06]: No healing for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: No healing.
[SPEAKER_04]: No healing, healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then that's it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Calder, yeah, you're 10 feet away from the guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Locke is rushing past in the square here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Felix is kind of out of danger ish.
[SPEAKER_02]: Although Billy is now right next to the woman.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's kind of looking around like what the fuck is going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I'm also starting to be a little bit confused about this going on over here.
[SPEAKER_06]: What is the general people doing over here now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Some people are starting to try and leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't want to get involved with the violence or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see a couple of people like some of the like, burlier sort of workers and porters and stuff start to look towards
[SPEAKER_02]: the area to try and assess like what's happening who's in the right but the thing is that these guys that you're fighting are in uniform and so you know that they might be sort of like
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but they, you know, the people are not yet 100% sure, like, are these guys, like, are you a thief trying to run away with their purse or something like that, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know what, they don't know the context of everything, though, they're on your side, probably mostly, but they don't want to just get involved and fight a guy in the streets just because it looks bad, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: But they are all like, there's a lot of people paying attention now to what is happening.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, hearing Felix saying that or yelling that to Lark that come this way.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I probably would also then run towards Felix again, but not going very deep into the alleyway.
[SPEAKER_06]: trying to keep line of sight on both of the guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: And if I can, I would want to prepare action to cast Chromatic Orb.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can I do like on either of the target?
[SPEAKER_06]: Like if they behave aggressively, then I can cast it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can hold your action for them acting aggressively and then cast it on them.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you rush to the entrance of the alleyway, hold a spell.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, next to Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Really?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now it's the woman's turn, but she is still incapacitated because it's not my turn yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That she gets back.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's unfortunate for her.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it is your turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I see Lark coming up towards us.
[SPEAKER_01]: I will cast Healing Ward.
[SPEAKER_01]: As I said,
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that a bonus section?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think so, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Healing word is a bonus section.
[SPEAKER_01]: There you go.
[SPEAKER_01]: You need some help back.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then, yeah, because we're trying to run away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I would, because I asked Felix, Felix, what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: So we just run or do you want to?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, should just run.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, then yeah, then now just run off with them as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you can dive into the other way of break line of sight.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Billy, the, the two combatants here are basically like one of them is kind of like days, the other one is frozen in place and your friends are running away, away from you at the moment.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, as a bonus action, I'm going to spit in this guy's face and then I'm just going to run again.
[SPEAKER_05]: You basically just continue your route.
[SPEAKER_02]: I will say that he's still quite far away from you, but you can use action in the dash, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, it's like a drive-by spit.
[SPEAKER_02]: His eyes are still locked on where Felix was.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you kind of like drive by past his gaze, get to the edge of the thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is his turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: How long is whole person?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it concentration for you Felix?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: At the end of its turn, it repeats the save.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So at the end of his term, which means he's not going to get the turn this time, he is going to try and break out again with some save.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: he just gets a blob of spit on his face as he is perfectly like frozen and cannot do anything about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think with that unless you guys want to do anything else you guys are basically clear at this point by the time he comes back around to their turns and they get to act you guys will be far into the alleyways block line of sight etc so you guys all basically pile together into the alleyway and head away and so we'll call the initiative there
[SPEAKER_02]: done.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where are you guys aiming to go?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, as soon as I run to you guys, I just go like, no, no, no, quick, we have to leave, they're looking for someone who knows Theo, just keep running.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just like, usher everybody to just run as fast as they can.
[SPEAKER_00]: And they're not stopping.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you get yeah, so like, so the rushes past and leads the group.
[SPEAKER_02]: But
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the destination here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Assuming that you're not like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, at least for this like initial alleyway area, you guys are together, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, it's sort of like, how long do you want to go for before you sort of take a breather and assess and what direction you're heading in?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you heading somewhere specific?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think, I don't know what everyone's doing, but if I, if we would just run, I would.
[SPEAKER_00]: lead us basically a little bit deeper to the stacks towards maybe the start of the bellows, like opening or something.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just follow her.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: After a couple of minutes of running at sort of full speed, nothing happens behind you, you're looking over your shoulder,
[SPEAKER_02]: you don't have there's no one pursuing you that you can tell you don't see the ailer suddenly kind of coming around the corner or anything behind you so you're pretty certain that you've lost them for now as you weave your way into the stacks and territory starts to become a bit more familiar for you lark as you aim as you sort of end up or for a lot of you actually but as you end up back into the into the close quit close quarters alleyways and stuff of the stacks here
[SPEAKER_02]: so you guys yeah so you can stop here and decide where you're going or you can lead them to a certain place or yeah what's one of you want isn't that like really close to my house it's yeah it's not far it's not far from your house probably like 20 minutes or something like that uh
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe, no, maybe only 10 minutes by the time you guys have run full speed from the Pollenbob, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're maybe about 10 minutes from Billy's house.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're maybe about 15, 20 from the brass line.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I might suggest then to the group, like, guys, I know a safe spot.
[SPEAKER_05]: Follow me and lead them to my house.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK. Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_04]: OK. Sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sounds good, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: As we follow Billy, I...
[SPEAKER_00]: catching my breath and I go next to Aska and I say I'm so sorry Mr. Aska I went to talk to the old man and those people they came in and they just didn't take no for an answer they were they were looking for someone who knows Tio I swear I didn't give out any names I didn't mention you I didn't mention Felix so I just tried to get away I'm so sorry yeah we got out safe
[SPEAKER_00]: But I think they will now probably bother the old man in the tavern.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because he was the only one with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I know...
[SPEAKER_01]: I already forgot his name.
[SPEAKER_05]: Barry Killerman, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Barry the not killer man.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he's not really...
[SPEAKER_01]: Unfortunately, he's not really our problem anymore now.
[SPEAKER_01]: We just have to stay safe and just make sure that this kind of thing won't happen again.
[SPEAKER_05]: How do we do that when they just come up to us like that?
[SPEAKER_05]: We didn't do anything wrong, we were just in a tavern.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's what they do and we don't really know much about this group at the moment.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't seem to recognize the clothes they're wearing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do any of you recognize them?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think, didn't they carry the Porter's Guild badge?
[SPEAKER_06]: At least a woman?
[SPEAKER_02]: They did.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think only Lark noticed that, being so close up to them.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, so did anyone get any information on who they are by their clothing or anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, and Lark explains like everything they had on them and then that she recognized the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she just says like, yeah,
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know why they wanted any names so badly for me, but they just didn't take no for an answer and they just got violent instantly.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's folk to be very.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it's so, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: So weird, because when I was asking some information a couple of days ago, people were talking a lot of different guilds and everything, but they were also speaking very carefully about Porter's guild.
[SPEAKER_06]: It somehow sounded mysterious almost, and now those guys are coming in.
[SPEAKER_06]: I really wonder what's going on within the guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Grimzin, I don't know if any of us would have any knowledge of the Portis Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a politics check, Aske.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can also make one lock, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: It makes sense for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the other three of you probably have no real dealings with
[SPEAKER_01]: Damn, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, she quits on this one, damn.
[SPEAKER_00]: It could be the courier stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, you've had the general education, Escar, about all the guilds.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you generally know what the Potters Guild does, where they're based, like, they are, they basically run the crews of people that transport goods around the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they're like a large guild with a lot of network and a lot of, generally a lot of influence because everybody is
[SPEAKER_02]: needs things moving around the city so therefore the pod is always useful for that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you know the structure of how the Porter's Guild works and everything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know that there's all these various different crews and all that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know all about that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you notice specifically that they were not just part of a crew from associated with the Porter's Guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: They specifically had Porter's Guild pins as if they work directly for basically like upper management type of situation, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So that obviously stood out to you as being more than just like some kind of inter rivalry between these different crews or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was more it was like the level above.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you guys head towards Billy's house, I guess.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess we follow.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you arrive at the stacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: It takes you a little while to sort of climb up the various ladders and ramps, but you get this great view of the city as you arrive high up on the side of the chimney where these sort of temporary buildings are built, which have become permanent over time.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you head down, yeah, and you head towards Billy's house, which is a small-ish but nicely maintained house quite high up in the stacks with a great view across the city.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is the evening at this point.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's probably about eight, nine o'clock at this point by the time you've traveled through the city to here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you know that your mother will be in, Billy, as you approach the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, just to add to previous about the Porters Guild, since the Brassline crew that Lark worked for is affiliated with the Porters Guild, she also mentioned that to the group that, not that she would have had anything to do with the Porters Guild,
[SPEAKER_00]: higher ups, but that she just knows that the brass line was associated with the guild that she worked for.
[SPEAKER_00]: She just mentioned that as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I think as well, because to reward the natural 20 as well, if you have any specific questions about the Portis Guild or something that you would want to know related to this, then maybe you can also get that with that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think she would have paid attention to anyone who came to the brass line offices and if she would have seen green coats like that, she would have probably paid a lot of attention to the people, what they looked like.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, no, I think thinking back, there would have been occasional visits from people in these green coats from from the sort of upper management of the Portis Guild, you get the.
[SPEAKER_02]: the idea that Mira probably was pretty hands-off when it comes to dealing with the politics of the of the guild overall and she would just pay her dues and be happy with it basically she wasn't like trying to be ambitious about working her way up or anything so she would have just had the kind of the regular essentially like tax collectors coming to you know get their dues but beyond that she didn't seem to have much interaction
[SPEAKER_06]: I have a general question.
[SPEAKER_06]: Does the doors have name tags over here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Not name tags, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think they have numbers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, numbers only.
[SPEAKER_02]: Numbers only, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think there's probably not an organized enough sort of post or service thing where you need like name tags or whatever, but
[SPEAKER_02]: But you guys arrive on one of these long balconies that leads towards Billy's house.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess you're leading the way, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you arrive at your front door.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know how I usually get in my house.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do I have a key?
[SPEAKER_05]: Usually through the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: You never know in these places.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you would have a key.
[SPEAKER_05]: There is like, yes, I guess I'll just like wave to the group and say, OK, guys, we're we'll be safe here for a bit.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I just open the door and.
[SPEAKER_05]: Come step in first.
[SPEAKER_05]: And as I do, I kind of call out into the room like.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mom, are you home?
[SPEAKER_02]: yeah and as you step inside yeah you see the back of your mother Annie who is working doing like washing up after after dinner at the little kitchenette thing at the far end of the room and she turns around at your voice and she goes oh Billy Billy oh I didn't I didn't expect you home so soon I thought you were out uh cavorting with your friends at the inn yes we did um
[SPEAKER_05]: Just guys, just get in, get in and shut the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: She rushes over and she says, Oh, Billy, these must be your friends.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pleasure to meet you all.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she kind of like looks over.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's a couple of people who are Billy's age, so it's not so weird.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then like Felix said, like,
[SPEAKER_02]: is a good 10 years older or almost 10 years older and also Eska and YouTube maybe don't look quite so similar so she looks over at the group in general and she says oh you have to you have to introduce me Billy it's great to meet some of your friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well I'm probably at the very back very shy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah I'm also at the back because for Eska it's really weird that this like
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy who's been so secretive all the time and not willing to share anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: All of a sudden he's like, oh, hey guys, come to my house.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's going to be great.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Eska is kind of suspicious and also just because he's suspicious of anybody in any case.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I'm behind with Lark.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think I would be kind of on the front.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I think I would also be in the front.
[SPEAKER_04]: I will shake mom's hand.
[SPEAKER_04]: Hello, I'm Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, pleasure to meet you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Pleasure to meet you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, you're being rude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Introduce us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Introduce your friends.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is Felix.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I point to Calder.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's Calder.
[SPEAKER_06]: Hello, Billy's mom.
[SPEAKER_05]: The not-so-good-looking guy.
[SPEAKER_05]: What was his name?
[SPEAKER_05]: Eska, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: And then the girl over there in the corner, that's Lark.
[SPEAKER_00]: I dropped to a 90 degree angle again, like, hello ma'am, I'm so sorry to disturb you.
[SPEAKER_02]: She says, no, no, no, not at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Come in, come in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll make teas for you all.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a pleasure to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's nice that Billy has some friends, you know, I mean, coming around the house for a change, you know, it's, it's excellent to meet you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_02]: She sort of shakes all of your hands one by one and, and she starts to walk over and like put the kettle on and everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you, it's an odd time to bring guests home, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you,
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mom, could you leave us for a bit?
[SPEAKER_05]: We have some stuff to talk about.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's kind of, yeah, you wouldn't be interested in any of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's still good.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make a persuasion check.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can have advantage.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's your mother.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you don't get advantage, I'm persuading your mother, Wendy.
[SPEAKER_02]: That would be hilarious.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are still whispering to me, man.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it was a really good number.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was a natural 20.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you don't have natural 20s turned on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think if you go to the you go to the cog wheel and is it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does anyone remember where it was?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, in the character sheet, next to the hit points, you see the sheet settings.
[SPEAKER_06]: And there is so natural 20s and 1s on all D20 rolls.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I don't.
[SPEAKER_05]: And you can highlight it then.
[SPEAKER_05]: I did it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: So yeah, natural 20.
[SPEAKER_02]: She goes, of course, Billy, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You and your friends have a nice little meeting.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll just, I'll just, I'll go water the plants out the back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't you worry.
[SPEAKER_02]: The tea will be ready soon.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can pour it, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: She heads out the back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, Billy, your mom is really nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, she has this.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's a very beautiful building.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's just, it's just anything, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Lots of people have the same house here.
[SPEAKER_05]: So anyway, I figured we could use a spot to lay low.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sorry, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just forgot the watering can.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me just grab that for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_05]: We
[SPEAKER_05]: I think Asuka was trying to explain something about how we should not get in trouble with those guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Before that, Billy, I do have a thing because why the sudden change of heart, Billy?
[SPEAKER_01]: You were very secretive, especially to me before about sharing anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: And now all of a sudden you're willing to tell us where you live and even shelter us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't get me wrong.
[SPEAKER_01]: I appreciate it.
[SPEAKER_01]: However, it's a sudden change.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, but I mean, look,
[SPEAKER_05]: I didn't know who to trust at first.
[SPEAKER_05]: But now that I feel that we are in danger, I feel like I should keep us somewhat safe.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not saying I fully trust everyone, but I guess I just don't really have any better ideas about what to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hark is just looking at the house like in awe, like, well, such a big house and but very making her so small in the room, not really taking any space, moving, moving anywhere, but just looking like such a nice house.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yes, I guess it's not common to all of us what's happening here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I unfortunately cannot tell you a lot more about this as let's just say for the past two years, I have been more hiding.
[SPEAKER_01]: So working my way around Tavern.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't really know anything that's going on in the politics of the, of that world anymore.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um,
[SPEAKER_01]: However, a good friend of mine who has been really good to me is now dead.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if anything, I feel we should or I used to think that I should be the one to look into this.
[SPEAKER_01]: But now, I guess, seeing as we have been through quite a bit and it seems like you guys haven't tried to kill me yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: You know, I guess, I guess, yes, I guess apologies are in due for me trying to cast a spell on you, Billy or Billy, sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Apologies for that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, look, I'll be honest, I didn't really want to meet back up with you guys because I felt like
[SPEAKER_05]: I didn't want to get in trouble anymore than we needed to, but I feel like trouble is coming to us anyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: So kind of don't really have a choice, but to kind of figure out what's going on.
[SPEAKER_05]: And especially with these
[SPEAKER_05]: These guys from the Porta Guild, they've been acting strange and they've been taxing Shrepnel, for example, at the scrapyard extra, extra much.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I figured... Just a correction, sorry, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the Artificers Guild that you saw, not the Porta Guild.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, we're going to take everything back.
[SPEAKER_02]: The guilds in general.
[SPEAKER_02]: Many guilds are being weird.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, you experienced that.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right when Theo wanted to make his statements and talk about it, he gets assassinated.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess something bad is going to happen and I feel like we
[SPEAKER_05]: really have no choice but to figure out who's behind all this stuff and maybe we can solve it together.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: So your second correction is the Core Rights Association, not the Arctic Association.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, I will say, yeah, if you say the Core Rights Association, Eske, you know that they are like associated with the Guild of Engineers, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So whilst it wasn't the Porters Guild, it was someone associated with the Guild of Engineers, separate factions or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: But certainly the guilds in general have been causing more problems for you guys in
[SPEAKER_02]: variety of ways.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah would it be like would it be then that like Asuka would see that this leads up to the Guild of Engineers in any ways or is it like not the case like
[SPEAKER_02]: So you know that the Core Right Association is sort of like allied, but not directly reporting to the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_02]: Basically, the Core Right Association is everything to do with Essence Cores specifically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they make them, they create items with them, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's kind of a specialized sub, it's like a niche industry.
[SPEAKER_02]: So they have their own guild, but they kind of basically do what the Guild of Engineers says most of the time, as far as you understand it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I guess like in Asuka's mind, there could be someone at the Guild of Engineers behind this without like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's a possibility in any case for him that somebody might be pulling the strings from way, way up ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, yeah, this is only talking about the case.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is only talking about the case that Billy is talking about where they kind of shook down his boss at the, the, the, the third party is the, is the porters guild, which I've nothing to do with the guild of engineers.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: That has to be clear there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: This also goes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Tell me about it.
[SPEAKER_05]: And was it, this is out of character, I remember someone, I think it was Calder who talked to an old guy, was a guy where he, like he said, oh, there's gotta be like a lot of essence needed to create a weapon like that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know if that was knowledge to all of us or just Calder.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think it was originally for me but I think I told that in the tavern that it needs some great skill and great resources.
[SPEAKER_05]: So that would make the link between the core rights association trying to get more money and possibly creating that weapon
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, yeah, I mean, you can make an engineering check, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think as you guys are having this conversation, anyone who wants to can make an engineering check to basically see how much you might know about these types of subjects.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that makes sense.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, so I think Calder and Felix, like it doesn't mean much to you guys, you understand what essence cores are essentially their batteries, just like a way of storing magical energy and reusing it inside machines.
[SPEAKER_02]: You obviously know the theoretics of it, Calder, but not really the mechanics of how they actually work and that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy you know a decent amount because most of what you do at the scrap yard, the most valuable stuff that you can scrap is essence cores, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: If you get anything that has an essence core in it, the number one thing is like, is that essence core intact?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can we take it out?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can we, you know, because they're just worth a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_02]: You estimate, I think from
[SPEAKER_02]: from your work that each essence core is probably worth like 20 to 30 ducats each, maybe sometimes even more than that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's a lot of money per core.
[SPEAKER_02]: And obviously, if you've got 10 of them or whatever, it's like more than a year's wage in just a box of them, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's quite a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Eski, you know that, yeah, like everything that the Guild of Engineers does basically requires essence cores.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you also were probably part of
[SPEAKER_02]: certain projects and things when you're at the Guild of Engineers, which were to do with finding ways to basically improve them, make them more efficient, use less of them to get more power, to use loads of them together to see what happens kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: These kind of experimental elements were quite commonplace in the Guild of Engineers as well when you were there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So all of these things do sort of link to Essence Cores from the various directions.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think once Calder explains as well about the fact that it would need a lot of power, you guys who have that sort of knowledge would be like, OK, a lot of power probably means a lot of Essence Cores.
[SPEAKER_05]: I need to go to the bathroom real quick.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have a short break.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, we can grab a break.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are close.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay, changing scene.
[SPEAKER_00]: I realized I didn't pause the recording.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we had stream on.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's going to be a bit weird for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: During the pause.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are these fucking guys doing, bro?
[SPEAKER_01]: Lip read it, you know?
[SPEAKER_01]: Lip reading stream.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have an idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: While you guys were talking about the weapons and engineering, which Lark doesn't know anything about, she tries to stealth check towards the balcony where Billy's mom headed.
[SPEAKER_00]: You think we have a balcony?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's like a, you have like a, I think it's more like a courtyard out the back where the house is close to the chimney to the wall of the chimneys there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And there's a bit of a gap where there's just some like plants and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can certainly get to the door easily.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if you can't really stealth out of the conversation,
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, just trying to like back up while they're talking, if they're not paying attention.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you will need a decent stealth role for this.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's five people in a conversation and one of them slowly sort of backs off towards the door.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think you kind of like make it towards the kitchenette kind of area.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, it's up to you guys if anyone, you kind of see like kind of like wandering away from the conversation a little bit as you guys are talking about.
[SPEAKER_02]: guns and this is X.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Eska is not noticing because this is Eska's alley right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: So there's like this part of his brain that used to be in the Guild of Engineering kind of triggers and he's like, oh my god, Essence.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think probably that's the same for Calder as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think William would notice because it's how he's a bit more looking like things aren't getting broken or anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, did you say anything as you see this, Billy, at all?
[SPEAKER_05]: Lark, do you need some fresh air or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just want to take a look at the yard.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't really have a yard, but I could show you around later if you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: An insight check into whether he has a yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Into luck, you're telling the truth.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, OK. That you were like, is he lying about having a yard?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just rolling shit again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: [Felix], your rolls have been terrible this session.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do we do?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's meet it to beat it, so he beats your check.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm lying.
[SPEAKER_02]: You both rolled a nine basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, I mean, Felix beats your check technically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's just like, whether you're telling the truth or not, or what he sees on Lark's face is she says that she just wants to look around a bit or whatever.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, she just has, she just is curious about something and just wants to like wander around.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are you going to do anything?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll let her be.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, OK.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I mean, you can head out if you want.
[SPEAKER_02]: If Billy's not going to stop you, you can go out of the back door where presumably.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not against her walking around, but we're also in a conversation with everyone.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's kind of weird that she's leaving.
[SPEAKER_00]: head out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you open you open up the back door and you see that there's like a yeah, it's like a kind of alleyway where the building is up against the brick of the chimney that it's built against.
[SPEAKER_02]: And was the top level kind of sits against flush against the chimney in order to get the warmth of the chimney, which is the reason that people build houses here in the first place.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is like this little arch over at the back, which is basically just where you can have some like,
[SPEAKER_02]: window boxes and it's very confined sort of like alleyway at the back of the house.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you do see that Annie, Billy's mom is there just watering some plants.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's got a nice like, I think a lot of like vegetable vegetables are growing here and herbs like whatever she can fit into these these window boxes.
[SPEAKER_00]: She didn't introduce herself like her name, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I don't think she did.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: But she turns as you open the door and she looks at you and she says, Oh, oh, um,
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you alright there?
[SPEAKER_00]: Apologies, I just wanted to take a look.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you really have plants here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, the good thing about being up this high, you know, is we get a lot of sunlight and we try and make the most of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you can see, I've got some renna beans growing here and some coriander.
[SPEAKER_00]: She just heads close to look really carefully at all the plants.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where are you from then?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, I've been around the Stacks mostly, but like not around here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, a little bit lower down towards the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I mean, a lot of lovely places down there in the Stacks, you know, I born and raised here myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, you know, I love the Stacks, high or low, the people here are great.
[SPEAKER_02]: How did you meet Billy?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, well, we were sort of in the same event.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where I met him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you're Billy's mom?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does he have a dad as well?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, his father works at the college.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a professor there.
[SPEAKER_02]: He works late and he has a lot of very important projects that he deals with, so he's not always around at home as much as we'd like, of course, but he's got a lot going on to be expected.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, that's really nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because you love insight checks.
[SPEAKER_02]: She just seems very sad about that as she says it.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's obviously trying to hide it, but she does seem very sad to say that Billy's father is not home very often.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I hope he gets some time off and gets to be
[SPEAKER_00]: home soon, I hope.
[SPEAKER_00]: But your house is really nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you, thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Our family was one of the first to move into the stacks, you know, and so we've, you know, this family house has been here for a long time and yeah, we're very proud of it and very happy to keep, be part of this community, you know, it's great here, even though some of the people in the rest of the city maybe don't appreciate it as much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd never move anywhere else, even if I could.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's thinking like, are they established names or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: But she doesn't dare to ask any surnames or anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: So she's just nodding carefully.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't want to disturb you anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you so much for allowing us to come in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Help yourself to anything in the kitchen, by the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the kettle should be done.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, Billy's not so great a host.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, you know, make sure you, you know, help yourself.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, he doesn't get guests very often.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we wouldn't want you being, you know, missing out on anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, we brew our brew some of our own mint here for the mint tea.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've got to try that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So please, please.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was your name again, ma'am?
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Annie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Annie Bugman.
[SPEAKER_00]: Buckman?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you were in the conversation where the name was mentioned anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, OK.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you, Annie.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, of course, of course.
[SPEAKER_00]: What was it, Lark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, yeah, pleasure, pleasure.
[SPEAKER_00]: You too.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she shyly heads back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sorry, you re-enter the room as everyone's sort of talking about how, yeah, about how essence cores would be needed and how power is one of the main issues with using a long range weapon and all this kind of like nerdy magic essence talk, engineering talk.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So anyways, back to magic essence.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where were we actually?
[SPEAKER_05]: To make that kind of energy and to have that amount of essence.
[SPEAKER_05]: They need like a lot of money or power to get that.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we also we know that the shot was fired from one of the guild spires.
[SPEAKER_05]: So I guess Billy would argue that it's likely that some kind of maybe one guild or multiple guilds have some kind of shady dealings.
[SPEAKER_05]: And for whatever reason, they wanted to assassinate Dio.
[SPEAKER_05]: It might be a good idea to kind of try to trace back how that weapon was maybe made.
[SPEAKER_05]: And in that way, maybe we could find the culprit or someone who's had some dealings with
[SPEAKER_05]: bad people, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I mean, it makes sense.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I ask an out-of-character question that I forgot in the beginning?
[SPEAKER_00]: Did Billy tell us that Theo's mom told him that Theo's body was never delivered to the hospital?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_00]: You didn't tell?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't even know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think Eska at this point would add Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Felix, how are things at the... Because I don't think Eska knows if that Felix has been fired, has he?
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys sort of assumed it from his comment.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fair, fair.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Felix, how were things at the Guild of Engineers when you got fired?
[SPEAKER_01]: Did anyone seem to be...
[SPEAKER_01]: Any kind of panic at all, or is it just business as usual?
[SPEAKER_04]: To be fair, I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_04]: I couldn't get in, so.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, but like when, when you were, when you were fired, because you were fired the day after you said.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So how were things the day after?
[SPEAKER_03]: You mean the day before he got fired, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, sorry, I mean the day after Theo died.
[SPEAKER_01]: Because he went to work the next day and then he got told that he was fired.
[SPEAKER_01]: So Aska wants to know how the situation then was.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just some clerks fired, just tried going through all this stuff, but they didn't take anything and just more business as usual.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nothing special.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I guess Theo didn't really have that important of a position for it to be a big thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: But, well, I myself went to Theo's house and tried to do some investigating, but I couldn't really find anything of use.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did any of you manage to find anything that would help us at the moment?
[SPEAKER_01]: I also went to his house, but I also didn't find anything, except it was rummaged already.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it was rummaged.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that might have been my dealing.
[SPEAKER_01]: When were you there?
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, okay, just to get the story.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I was there.
[SPEAKER_02]: It was roughly the morning and Felix went in roughly the afternoon.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, because I know the night after the killing, the people were
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So then in his house already.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I, oh, wait, no, then if I come in the morning after that, then it would have been rummaged already.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: When you, when you broke your way in Asker had already been searched and searched by someone who didn't break the door down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's another fact, I guess, for you, because it was locked when you arrived.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, but yeah, it had already been searched before you, you got there, both of you basically.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Um,
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So then I would say, uh, well, no, uh, when I, when I went through it, uh, it was already rummaged as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I went pretty early the next morning, so it must've been done during the night.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also the skeptical thing was, uh, that it was locked when I tried to enter.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, and the door wasn't broken down or anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: So someone, whoever rummaged it must've had a key.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, so it was probably someone inside of the guild.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Or someone with very good lockpicking skills.
[SPEAKER_04]: To also lock it again.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, well, yeah, I don't know if you can use lockpicking skills to lock it again, but I guess you could, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think you could, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But whether you would or not is, you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: But Mr. Eska and Mr. Felix, you are...
[SPEAKER_00]: the people who I know are close to Theo or were close to Theo and the portrait skilled members were looking for someone like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I worry for you, Mr. Felix, because you were right next to him for a year.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your face is very known for people who know Theo.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you might be in the greatest danger if someone's really trying to look for someone close to Theo.
[SPEAKER_04]: But luckily, I don't have a house anymore, so it's a bit harder to find me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm just saying on the street.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, as you say that, um, Felix, you still need to go and clear your house out.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have been kicked out of your house, but you haven't taken your stuff anywhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: So your stuff is still at your house and you have until the end of today to, well, you were told that you were evicted.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have until the end of today to get out.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's something given that it's eight or nine PM that you might do as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just as a... And you haven't told us the characters that you are even homeless now?
[SPEAKER_02]: But he just told you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, I was thinking about the plants outside.
[SPEAKER_03]: But you don't have a home?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, like where are you going to sleep now?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't know yet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sure I can work out with the...
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the name?
[SPEAKER_01]: How to get you a place at the plumber.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, but that would be nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, we will have to at least wait until tomorrow because for the situation to die down a little bit, we can't go back there today.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah, it's not a possibility.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess we're going to have to ask
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not sure if Billy's house is going to fit all of us.
[SPEAKER_01]: How big it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe not all of us.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, uncomfortably, you can all fit in.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, there's not enough beds or whatever, but there's definitely enough floor to sleep on in the room, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: There's only three rooms basically in the house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I doubt my father is coming home.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you talking this out loud?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I'm thinking out loud.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, I have the idea.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wait, one second.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'll walk outside to mom.
[SPEAKER_05]: To mom.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to walk to the store to take listen in.
[SPEAKER_00]: Listen in?
[SPEAKER_00]: OK, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, have you served the tea to the guests?
[SPEAKER_05]: I will do that soon.
[SPEAKER_05]: I actually have a question.
[SPEAKER_05]: Some of these people are homeless and I was wondering if...
[SPEAKER_05]: um if they could stay over just for tonight if that could be a thing oh like a sleepover oh yeah yeah yeah yeah of course i must say they don't they they look very respectable so yeah and i know you've said like no girls over but i i think this is it's never been a problem before billy has it so uh yeah that's true i haven't really ever had a sleepover so it's quite exciting
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, no, I think it's great that you've made some friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is she not suspicious at all?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's like, older men.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why is he having sleepovers?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, well, I think that she assumes that it's the younger people and the older men are going to go back to their houses.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's the old men who are homeless now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because you haven't said who, you just said the things you're just assuming.
[SPEAKER_02]: Especially when Lark said Lark was a little bit like...
[SPEAKER_02]: non-specific about where she lived in the stacks and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that would be the obvious person.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then she doesn't know much about Calder, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think she's assuming, but you don't, you know, but either way she says.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Of course, Billy, that's no problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: No problem at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, I think it's great to, you know, help out people, you know, the city can be rough sometimes and, you know, of course be a bit of a squeeze.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, how many, how many of.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not sure, actually.
[SPEAKER_05]: I should probably ask first.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, yes, of course, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I run away from the door as I hear that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretending that I wasn't.
[SPEAKER_05]: This guy is an insider just seeing Lark run that fast.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just like what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you guys see Lark just like listening in at the door.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Who needed a place to stay, actually?
[SPEAKER_04]: I asked the group.
[SPEAKER_04]: Me.
[SPEAKER_05]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I would prefer staying here, yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like I said, it's not wise to go back to the Pullman Bob after what just happened today.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Felix and Aska.
[SPEAKER_05]: Kalle, you have a place to go to, right?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I do have, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: What about you, Mark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, I have a place.
[SPEAKER_05]: inside you.
[SPEAKER_05]: I just wanted to do it once.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is what it feels like to lead.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm rolling.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well then ask on Phoenix, I think I I can we can work it out for tonight and then we can Actually, what day is it We work today, right and then as well you work today so Yeah
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, not all of us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Then tomorrow we can maybe find a permanent solution or a different temporary one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Imagine not having a job.
[SPEAKER_05]: My mom said it was fine if you wanted to stay over.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would be very appreciated.
[SPEAKER_06]: sleepover party with two older men.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy's mom's gonna love it.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm so glad I didn't make like a minor guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's probably bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: So is it Earth Day?
[SPEAKER_02]: Today is Earth Day, tomorrow it is Wex Day, the third day of the week, which would be a working day generally for those of you who have
[SPEAKER_02]: jobs, which is actually only Billy.
[SPEAKER_00]: We didn't we met on what the fuck are the days?
[SPEAKER_02]: You met on Kinsday.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kinsday was Theo's murder.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then Ailes day was the day after.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then Earth's day is today.
[SPEAKER_02]: So tomorrow is Wicks day.
[SPEAKER_02]: The days are in the calendar and seasons thing.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, but we were two days away.
[SPEAKER_00]: You are wrong.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's Wex Day today.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look at the chronicle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your chronicle is wrong, dude.
[SPEAKER_00]: We were supposed to meet on Wex Day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, that's true, but you didn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: You met on Earth Day.
[SPEAKER_02]: You originally agreed to meet two days later, but then you actually all ended up meeting the day before on Earth Day instead of on Wex Day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where we all like that's kind of that was kind of my fault because I said, what are you doing in the evening?
[SPEAKER_02]: And you guys all just went to the Plum and Bob in the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even though you all agreed to meet on Wex Day, you didn't actually you didn't have two nights of sleep yet.
[SPEAKER_02]: We did.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've had the field.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've had the night of fear's death.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's one night.
[SPEAKER_02]: Then you had the second night, which was the end of Ales Day.
[SPEAKER_02]: And now it's Earth Day, Tuesday, the second day of the week and tomorrow be Wex Day, which is Wednesday, the third day of the week.
[SPEAKER_02]: Chronicle is correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, we'll check this after.
[SPEAKER_02]: Chronicle is always correct.
[SPEAKER_03]: Chronicle is correct because it's built on transcripts.
[SPEAKER_02]: Chronicle is correct.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's 100% correct, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have to count my birthday again.
[SPEAKER_00]: God damn it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tomorrow is Wex Day, all right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tomorrow is Wex Day, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know why you're confused, because we originally said in episode one, let's meet back here on Wex Day.
[SPEAKER_02]: But then what happened is nobody did that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everybody met on the day before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody took the extra day to go and do stuff before meeting at the Pum and Bob, because it was just, there wasn't a need to, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So it was fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys just ended up, so we just retconned that, that you said it was day and it's fine, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Whatever.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Also, we haven't really discussed anything that was really, like,
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we're kind of stumped on what to do right now, because nobody knows anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, like, we know, like, parts of things that are useful, but.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think you guys have some leads.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you guys have found some leads.
[SPEAKER_02]: All of you, either individually or together, have found some various leads.
[SPEAKER_02]: How you move on those is up to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And whether you even realize their leads is on you guys, I'm not going to tell you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think there's some things, but it is getting later in the evening here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the one pressing thing that I can say for sure is that Felix needs to go to his house to get his shit because because they're going to throw out on the street if you don't.
[SPEAKER_04]: So that's one thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I assumed that you didn't kind of like wander around during the day with all of your like all of your pairs of clothes on, you know, and everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, that's one thing that is pressing, but otherwise, yeah, I mean, you have a place to stay here at Billy's, but up to you guys, what do you do next?
[SPEAKER_05]: How do people usually stay in contact with each other?
[SPEAKER_05]: Like they don't have mobile phones, obviously.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is a lot of people that can use the sending spell and the message cantrip.
[SPEAKER_02]: without too much effort.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that's one way.
[SPEAKER_02]: But outside of that, it would be letters or something like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if you needed to like meet someone on the day, you'd have to just go to where they work or where they normally hang out to try and find them basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: There'd be sort of fax machine type of engineering.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not like a fax machine, I think what you would do is go to a place that does messages for you, like you can basically get someone to send a message cantrip or a sending spell to someone if you need to, for that sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But again, it's like using resources for that is probably outside of budget for the average person, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: So where should we meet tomorrow, guys?
[SPEAKER_00]: And what time?
[SPEAKER_05]: Or is not a good idea anymore, unless we can sneak in, like, in the back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I will head to the plumbing bar tomorrow because I do need to perform during the evening.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think there are other pubs you could go to ask.
[SPEAKER_02]: if you wanted to avoid one more.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mr Eska, I think it would be good to maybe figure out if they harmed the old man in case he knew something as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe he gave lots of names.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's also the reason I want to go back.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I will during the day look for
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I guess like during the day it would be wise for me to just go on with my daily routines and find some work in another pub and then during the night to head to the Pom & Bob to check up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or should it be the first?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just trying to think as my character here.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can go to a pub and try to find some work and then I'll go to the Plum and Bob and ask for things.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, that works.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Got nothing better to do.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we'll go with that because yeah, that guy's really, really, really careful about what he does.
[SPEAKER_01]: So.
[SPEAKER_06]: So Felix, are you going to your home this evening at all?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm a bit in doubt.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not a lot of stuff and maybe showing my face is also not really smart anymore.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fair enough, fair enough.
[SPEAKER_03]: So I think I'll just let them throw my stuff out.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'll just get some new clothes.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I guess after work, I'll find you guys at the Love and Bob again.
[SPEAKER_03]: I guess so.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you guys go to make these plans and you know Billy sort of tells Annie if these two guys can sleep over at the house or whatever and you guys go to potentially like split up and head out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, you hear a familiar voice in your head.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is Harriet Spurnhold's voice and you hear her say to you, obviously through ascending spell of some kind, you hear her say
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is really important.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Bellows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Subterminal 8T.
[SPEAKER_02]: Find it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meet me there at midnight.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she gets kind of almost cut off.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, this ending spell doesn't work like that, but you kind of hear like a rushed kind of voice as she says that to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll tell the group what I just heard and I guess I have to leave again this night.
[SPEAKER_04]: Who is that?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, who is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is it your wife?
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't have a wife.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you don't have a wife?
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: Girlfriend maybe?
[SPEAKER_06]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_06]: Boyfriend?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know if Eska would know her, I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_02]: It depends if you say the name.
[SPEAKER_04]: The secretary, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, she was the head secretary who was also fired at the same time as you from the guild.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so Eska would know her.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, at least by name.
[SPEAKER_02]: My title as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you're saying that Tarius contacted you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess you should go.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did she tell you where to meet?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, she did.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you know where this is?
[SPEAKER_05]: Would you guys go together?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I don't like the below so much.
[SPEAKER_05]: Is that okay?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, Harry has sent a message to Felix for a reason, and I don't think it would be wise for me to show my face to her at this time.
[SPEAKER_05]: Right.
[SPEAKER_05]: So what do you think, Felix?
[SPEAKER_05]: Should we join you?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, how do you feel?
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, I think before any of that, make a municipality check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Definitely need to change the name of that skill.
[SPEAKER_05]: The most boring skill in D&D.
[SPEAKER_05]: Very useful.
[SPEAKER_05]: You want to learn another Dutch word, [Lark]?
[SPEAKER_05]: Gemeenteraad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gemeenteraad.
[SPEAKER_05]: What does it mean?
[SPEAKER_05]: It's like municipality.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's literally local municipality.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: The word for that is shorter than yours.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's kinda simple either.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's actually Kanta.
[SPEAKER_01]: Kanta.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kanta.
[SPEAKER_03]: Kanta.
[SPEAKER_03]: Focus, guys, focus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Beautiful.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah, yeah, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yes, with the 16 in your Kunta check, you don't know the way to subterminal 18.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, you have no real knowledge of the bellows, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: That doesn't mean anything to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll ask the rest.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does anyone know where that is?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think Lark know, at least you probably don't know the specific place, but you know how to get to a place with that designation.
[SPEAKER_02]: So does Calder.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think the rest of you don't, because you probably don't know the bellows well enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Calder and Lark, you guys would know how to navigate the bellows.
[SPEAKER_04]: I do need someone with me who knows where to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll come with you.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you want more company?
[SPEAKER_06]: I also am somewhat familiar with the place.
[SPEAKER_00]: Don't you have a family that waits for you at home?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I live in the institute.
[SPEAKER_05]: No wife or girlfriend, unfortunately.
[SPEAKER_06]: But yeah, I'm most of the time sleeping in the institute anyway, so in the dorm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_06]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wow.
Wow.
[SPEAKER_05]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_06]: I can play music too guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Talking about music, before you leave, Eska will say, well, I hope she can tell you more about what's going on and I hope that you can figure out more things happening here.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why now we're kind of in the dark.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here, take this.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you get mental of inspiration.
[SPEAKER_01]: For the three of you who are going.
[SPEAKER_06]: With three?
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get temporary hit points equal to two times the number rolled on the dice.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do I need to roll?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, roll your bardic inspiration dice whatever the, I think it's a d6, a level three?
[SPEAKER_01]: Which is a d6, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll d6.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, you get six health.
[SPEAKER_01]: Congrats.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does it say how long this lasts for?
[SPEAKER_02]: We get six health.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it doesn't.
[SPEAKER_01]: Six temporary health.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, it's two times, sorry, four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four temporary hit points, but it doesn't say how long that lasts, does it?
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: I guess it would be until long rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but it also gives you the ability to use your reaction to move up to its speed without provoking opportunity attacks, so it's an in-combat thing, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's designed to be used in combat normally.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if it lasts long enough, then fine, that's no problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it doesn't say on there how long it lasts.
[SPEAKER_00]: Would this be considered as a short rest as we were sitting here, standing here talking?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, great.
[SPEAKER_00]: In that case, I would want to roll hit dice.
[SPEAKER_00]: For health?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can definitely do that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I bet this time I also have poor tea.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: The tea is safe.
[SPEAKER_01]: My mom will be proud of me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I can't see any mention of actually how long it lasts.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, same.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to say it's until a long rest, because that is the longest thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the longest time things don't last long.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was looking for it as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you guys get four temporary HP.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys take short rests.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's only three hours until midnight.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's about 9 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_02]: It won't take you three hours, but you will need to get a bit of a move on to get down the stacks, find the place in the bellows, etc.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys will have to leave relatively soon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy and Asuka, you guys are staying at home.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you guys, we'll start with the three that leave.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys heading down can make a, someone, I will say it's a group survival check just for kind of like navigating through the city, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_01]: A mom who's home alone without the dad.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry, I forgot the dad already because he's not home.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, fuck, sorry, I was focusing on more important things.
[SPEAKER_02]: On the mom.
[SPEAKER_02]: More important things.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, Lark sort of leads the way, but all of you have a decent time in terms of like leading through the city and heading towards the thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can also make municipality checks.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys identify the direction that you need to go for this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me put you guys back on the map for a while.
[SPEAKER_02]: Heading sort of this direction and then off in this direction a little bit to get to the best kind of location where you can enter the bellows.
[SPEAKER_02]: You slip down into the bellows and find yourself in the more residential area of the bellows here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll put you guys on the map.
[SPEAKER_02]: These are closer to the chimney.
[SPEAKER_02]: These are smaller tunnels where there are a lot more doors.
[SPEAKER_02]: And people live down here in these kind of small houses, wherever they've been able to find places to sleep and rest, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's a few turns and movements.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you basically are using your internal maps, Lark, and Calder to sort of go, OK,
[SPEAKER_02]: So sub terminal is sub terminal 8T that must be near like tunnel number eight somewhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then T means it's whatever, you know, like, and you start to like use your knowledge of the bellows to hone in on this location.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're moving, I pay very close attention to sounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I just also say to Caldera Felix that it's pretty late, so let's try to be quiet.
[SPEAKER_06]: I agree.
[SPEAKER_06]: By the way, Lara, how are you familiar with this place?
[SPEAKER_06]: It doesn't seem like you would be moving over here very much.
[SPEAKER_00]: Really?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I've lived here plenty.
[SPEAKER_06]: Ah, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's how.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you guys moving stealthily or you just want to move cautiously?
[SPEAKER_02]: Stealthily will be slower, but...
[SPEAKER_02]: Cautiously and alert.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cautiously not necessarily stealthy, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys can also just make perception checks as well then.
[SPEAKER_00]: Damn, I'm rolling so well!
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's get all these good rolls out of the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lark, especially, you have...
[SPEAKER_02]: encountered dangers down here before and know what to listen out for as well so you are especially on high alert as you listen out but in these areas that are a bit more residential where people actually live it seems from what you know that like the below boys operate in these types of areas a little less often because you know doing crime right outside somebody's house is a good way to get you know to make enemies right
[SPEAKER_02]: So, so heading through these areas, it seems less problematic.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys eventually find your way to like terminal eight, and then the terminal refers to like a circular room which has a bunch of tunnels that run off it basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: it's just like a place that's like a crossroads of sorts but more than four tunnels often and sub-terminal is another one of those that's like further on down a particular tunnel so you start to head down those those ways and you get into a bit more unfamiliar territory people don't live in these in this particular area as much but it's maybe a thoroughfare that occasionally you would have to go through
[SPEAKER_02]: Eventually you find yourself arriving at a more open room where there is a single steam outlet in the center and the steam kind of goes straight up into this circular room and out through grates in what would be like the ground level of the city and up and away basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this room is quite steamy and full of like kind of smoke curling at the edges as you come in.
[SPEAKER_02]: guess, Lark leading the way, you come to the edge of a tunnel which looks out into this circular room and you're in a position where you are quite hidden before you enter the room, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can make another perception check here, just you as the first person to arrive.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good, good, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see the shadowy figure of someone on the opposite side of the room in amongst the billowing sort of steam and smoke.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't know what this person looks like that you're here to meet, but there is just one person standing here as well that you can see on the opposite side of the room.
[SPEAKER_00]: I stop Calder and Felix with my hands like, wait, there's someone there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Felix, do you see the silhouette?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it look familiar?
[SPEAKER_00]: I look at it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Mr. Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, and I think it's like out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Certainly like a medium height, probably female.
[SPEAKER_02]: As far as you can tell from here, it could be Harriet, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: It looks like her.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, I think me and Calder should stay here.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll watch over you.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'll walk forward.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll say to Calder, like, I'll just take a little bit more higher ground if I can.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'll just try to get, climb on a crate or something, get against the wall and just look around the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you get yourself up into that, into the side as you kind of look and the Felix, are you just walking out into the room?
[SPEAKER_02]: How are you approaching the like, the woman?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll walk into the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you're just walking out confidently into the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, back at Billy's house, which does require tense music, obviously, not the tunnels.
[SPEAKER_02]: Back at your house, Billy, your mum is starting making arrangements for everyone to kind of sleep and that sort of thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she says, Billy, what happened to the rest of your friends?
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, yeah, so, um, well, I guess they had something.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, anyway, um, I kind of try to brush over the topic because I don't really know what to say.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, but at least, you know, ask us here.
[SPEAKER_05]: Um, did you know that he is a musician?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_02]: A musician?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, wow.
[SPEAKER_02]: A really good one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a pleasure to... Would I have heard you play anywhere?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you famous, Mr Aske?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, I play in a couple of pubs and bars.
[SPEAKER_01]: I wouldn't call myself famous.
[SPEAKER_01]: I just try to earn a living by playing in different bars, really.
[SPEAKER_01]: Maybe if you visited one of them, you would have seen me play before.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I mean, I, I don't really get out to the pubs that much, you know, shift work, you know, I'm back and forward, don't have too many free evenings to, to go and hang out at pubs and things like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe my, my early years, you know, but not these days.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy needs looking after, you know, she's a pats Billy on the head.
[SPEAKER_02]: And, well, I mean, would you play something for us, perhaps?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, if we're going to...
[SPEAKER_01]: I glare at Billy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can definitely...
[SPEAKER_01]: It's the least I can do for you helping us, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, yeah, I... How's that?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're wonderful.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I take out the orachim glaring at Billy, like, thanks for throwing me in front of the bus.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I, yeah, I just play...
[SPEAKER_01]: I just play a nice and calming tune, and just slow, not too fast, and yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can make a performance check.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's an important one.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is very important.
[SPEAKER_01]: If I fail, Billy's mom's going to kick me out of the house.
[SPEAKER_00]: She's the most important.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my God, it was a one, but also a 24.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, oh, I threw one on the performance deck.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would have.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a shame you haven't done it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But no, I mean, you play it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, this is your this is your profession.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is your calling.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are an excellent musician and you are able to easily play a song just to impress Billy's mom here and Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, Billy, you would have heard Asuka play before as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I mean, it's a bit different, obviously, being
[SPEAKER_02]: kind of like having a private performance.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is an impressive musical song as you guys sit there and Billy and his mum begin to listen to Asuka's talk, et cetera.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not talk, but performance.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why did I say talk?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: So meanwhile, here in Subterminal 8T, you walk out into the room
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you quickly see that this is Harriet Spernhold.
[SPEAKER_02]: She is still wearing the same sort of secretary clothing that you saw her in at this point yesterday when you last saw her.
[SPEAKER_02]: But she is looking really shifty and looking left and right as she sees you and spots you and for a second she's like
[SPEAKER_02]: relieved as she realized that it's you know she sees someone moving she's a little shocked and then she looks over and she's like relieved that it is actually you who is approaching her um i'll just uh where's her picture
[SPEAKER_02]: She is holding, in her hands, a ledger, much like this picture.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she is shifting side to side, incredibly nervous, you don't need an insight check or anything to tell that she is not in a comfortable position here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she sees you and she quickly beckons you over towards her, Felix, and says, um, Felix, Felix, I, uh,
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm sorry about the intrusion.
[SPEAKER_02]: I try not to use sending on anyone who's not expecting it, but this really was an emergency.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's been crazy since Theo was killed.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, how much do you know about Theo's dealings outside of the guild?
[SPEAKER_04]: Don't know much about it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I sort of assumed, I guess, that he might have.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I mean, I think you know that he has a few other, let's say, side projects, maybe.
[SPEAKER_02]: And during the
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, directly after his death, when the rest of the Guild of Engineers came to inspect his office, I had locked it in order to delay their search further.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was me that had locked it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I actually went straight to his house that night that he was killed to fetch this.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she holds up the ledger in her hand.
[SPEAKER_02]: He gave me a key a long time ago.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think he even remembered that I still had it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I thought it would be easier to find.
[SPEAKER_02]: I made somewhat of a mess in his house, but it was important to him that this was kept secret.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she hands it over to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she says,
[SPEAKER_02]: The important thing in here is this is a log of some of the, how do we put this, requisitioned materials from the guild that are being
[SPEAKER_02]: redirected from their correct allocations into some more useful locations by Theo.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I've been helping him to sort of make sure that the books reflect this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You open up the ledger and you can make a engineering check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again, this is not something that you're particularly
[SPEAKER_02]: knowledgeable about as you look at this ledger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a list of technical names and numbers, some of it even in language that you don't understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is like a list of numbers next to labels, but it is like a ledger book that basically has a list of items that run down.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she says,
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm pretty sure that the guild knew about me dealing with Theo.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why they fired me.
[SPEAKER_02]: And because they fired you, I assumed that perhaps you were also involved and he just not mentioned it.
[SPEAKER_02]: They certainly maybe think that you're involved with this sort of stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I think I managed to keep it all out of their hands.
[SPEAKER_02]: The really important thing, bang, she gets shot straight in the face as she is talking and falls backwards into the fog.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_04]: Just run straight back to where I came from.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, back at the house of Billy and Oscar.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why is everybody getting shot next to me?
[SPEAKER_02]: No bad luck, Felix.
[SPEAKER_01]: I really need a small violin or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Back at the house, Billy, as you are listening to this song play basket, you hear a jingling of keys in the door.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, I guess dad's home, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Mom.
[SPEAKER_02]: She also looks towards the door as the door opens and coming through the door is a figure that obviously you recognize your father, Benjamin.
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks at you, Billy, and then he looks at your mother, and then he looks at Asuka, slightly puzzled here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you link the image to us as well?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, did I not?
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks over at you three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, you can make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_02]: Against my father?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes, this is against your father.
[SPEAKER_05]: I want to do something.
[SPEAKER_05]: Would you say it's like an important...
[SPEAKER_05]: Roll or just any random?
[SPEAKER_05]: Up to you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, you forced me to roll.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is like, I mean, his initial reaction as he opens the door, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: You see on his face, you are trying to read the emotions of his face.
[SPEAKER_02]: You rolled a one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Up to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: What happens after that?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't actually, I should have done it before rolling, so it doesn't.
[SPEAKER_05]: OK, sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, with a one, you're just shocked, obviously not expecting him to turn up either.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, Aske, you can also make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, let's see.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is a look of recognition on his face as he looks at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: and kind of looks confusedly around the room.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Annie breaks the tension and immediately jumps up and says, oh, Benjamin, you're home.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't expect you.
[SPEAKER_02]: We didn't.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we obviously didn't know when you'd be back.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's great.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's great to see you back.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she sort of heads over towards him.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think, yeah, Billy and Eska, you see there's like an awkward kind of like hug that does not
[SPEAKER_02]: that does not sit right with you guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, it doesn't seem like they like each other at all in this moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he says, yes, look, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: My dad.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't realize you had a guest.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he's clearly sort of like stumbling for words a little bit here as he looks at Esker as well.
[SPEAKER_05]: It wasn't planned.
[SPEAKER_05]: But this is Asuka.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's just one of my new friends.
[SPEAKER_05]: And he needed a place to stay for just tonight.
[SPEAKER_05]: One of your friends?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, friends might not be the word.
[SPEAKER_05]: You know, I hang out with people, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume you do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks at you, Eske, and he has that expression of like, what are we doing here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Like, is anyone going to say anything kind of thing?
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks at you for your reaction.
[SPEAKER_01]: yeah I guess for now I'll just for now I'll just because I have changed in the last two years I am hoping that I can just get away with it so I will I will introduce myself hi my name is Eska and yeah I met Billy in one of the pubs that I played at and yeah now he
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, we get along.
[SPEAKER_01]: Billy likes my songs.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he asked me to come home and do a performance for him and for his mother.
[SPEAKER_01]: So here I am.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, pleasure to have you in my home, Eske.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he extends his hand to Shikha.
[SPEAKER_01]: The pleasure is mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then I bow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: You leave him hanging on the handshake?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, leaving him hanging on the handshake.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He pulls his hand back slightly and you hear in your head, Asuka, his voice as he says, uh, what are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_02]: And you can reply to this message.
[SPEAKER_01]: Uh, I reply, uh,
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a long story.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't have time to explain it now.
[SPEAKER_01]: But know that I don't mean your wife or your son any harm.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as this happens, Billy, you're watching as his, as your father extends his hand and he's using that to point towards Asuka for the messaging cantrip.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, his hand is just like hovering there and then him and Asuka are looking at each other for like longer than they should be, because obviously they're talking in their head briefly.
[SPEAKER_02]: So something is a little odd here, but obviously Asuka finishes the bow and Annie says, um,
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yes, the gentleman here, Asuka, will be staying here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe Billy's also got some other friends, I think some of which might be staying as well, Billy?
[SPEAKER_05]: I thought Felix would stay but he had to go somewhere so I don't think he's coming back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right okay yes sure um but uh yes of course you um and Benjamin just kind of walks past Annie and he says um I uh look I won't be staying long uh I have uh some research that I had stored here that I need to collect um Well you're not staying?
[SPEAKER_02]: No uh very busy very busy at the moment at the Guild uh
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, you've been away for a while.
[SPEAKER_05]: What have you been doing?
[SPEAKER_05]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_02]: He looks at you, Billy, and then he looks at Esker, and then he looks back at you, and he goes,
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not really something that I can get into in detail.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, you know how it is with some of the top levels of these types of organizations.
[SPEAKER_02]: They want to keep everything secret.
[SPEAKER_02]: They want to keep everything behind closed doors.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Actually, there's something I wanted to talk to you about if you have some time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, come with me.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll go out.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll go to the yard.
[SPEAKER_02]: And he walks towards the back door.
[SPEAKER_05]: Go, go, go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you follow him to the back door?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: And leaving you, Eske, and Annie in the main living room, Eske, if you want to do anything as this happens?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just going to wait for now.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, splattered with blood in the sub-terminal, Felix, a gunshot rings out and the three of you can immediately roll perception checks to see if you can identify the direction of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Huge.
Fail.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are we doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: All doing perception?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, perception as well, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, as the closest to where the shot landed, it was close, so it's from somewhere like nearby Felix and Calder as well, like it is probably, so if you guys are entering the room and Felix crossed the room going north, then it's probably from the east, if that makes sense, so it's on the right of you and if Felix turns around it would be on his left, if he's facing back towards you.
[SPEAKER_02]: so that shot rings out immediately it hits Harriet and she drops to the ground you're still holding the ledger there's a blood splat over you and she is like choking out on the ground as this shot has hit her in the neck there is like a magical burn across her neck and she's not dead but she is for intent for the mechanics unconscious on the ground bleeding out
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you guys can roll initiative, probably, as we resolve this.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yikes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm panicking.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the good thing is, because I pre-prevent this, you guys know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, do we have the same deck?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Whoa.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think so.
[SPEAKER_01]: How does that?
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_00]: The heck is this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why is this so wrong?
[SPEAKER_01]: What the heck am I?
[SPEAKER_01]: What am I seeing on my screen, Crimson?
[SPEAKER_01]: Why are there like three different pictures showing on my screen like this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what do you see?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's like the initiative thingy.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, but like, you're three.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's moving the pictures.
[SPEAKER_01]: OK. Yeah, I am.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you guys can move the pictures, actually.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: But no, these are the three characters in the scene.
[SPEAKER_02]: It just means that when you roll initiative, it goes to the initiative board for this.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why it's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Locke is dancing.
[SPEAKER_05]: So that's her panicking.
[SPEAKER_01]: Carter's dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So from the top.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Calder is the first one to react to this.
[SPEAKER_02]: As you see this happen, Felix is about 20 feet across the room from you, partially covered by this steam vent that's in the center.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you see the body kind of flop to one side.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can see that she is kind of lying on the opposite side of the room.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, there is nothing I can do to help her, but I would want to rush in to see if I spot the shooter anyhow.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: To where are you rushing?
[SPEAKER_02]: So with 30 feet you can basically get to the other side of the room if you want or, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I want to rush towards the direction that I was thinking the shoot was coming from.
[SPEAKER_06]: Towards the east.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this would be the east.
[SPEAKER_02]: This room is circular, but for the purposes of this, the tunnels go off two to the northwest, two to the northeast, two to the southeast, two to the southwest, like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So there's eight tunnels coming into this room.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is literally just designed as a place for all these tunnels to meet.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you rush towards the east.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I would yell out for you instantly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Calder, no, don't.
[SPEAKER_06]: Too late, unfortunately, for Calder.
[SPEAKER_02]: As he rushes around to the tunnel where he kind of towards the area where he heard the shot from, you look down the next tunnel along from you guys, you guys are on the southeast tunnels, the next southeast tunnel from you, you come around the corner to see in the tunnel
[SPEAKER_02]: a hound thing, roughly dog-sized, but sleek and engineered to...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you've probably seen these before, rarely, Calder, but certainly never had to fight one or anything like that, so you have no idea of its capabilities, but on its haunches, it's not growling because they don't growl, but it is a constructed
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it a howl?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, don't we all know about the constructs?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's a howl, but I think make an engineering check, Calder.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you know of howls in general being these like dog-like constructs.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is not, this is not your standard kind of like dog-like construct.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is a modified howl built for, well, you don't know what it's built for, but it looks more dangerous than a regular dog.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, it's like encountering a, like a wolf or like a, as opposed to a dog, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or something, a more dangerous type of dog in this scenario.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it's looking aggressive, probably.
[SPEAKER_06]: It looks aggressive, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's on its haunches.
[SPEAKER_02]: You get the impression that if it was a dog, it would be growling.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's not a dog, so it doesn't make noise.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it looks like it's ready to pounce, to leap, to rush forwards, yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I don't see anyone else, no.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, because yeah, as you rush forward, well, it's up to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You rush forward, this thing is right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You used about 15 feet of your movement to get halfway across the room to the east in this direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: You could keep going, but you would you're basically in melee with this thing because you've just come around the corner and it's right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if you continue to move, you will take an opportunity to attack.
[SPEAKER_00]: How big is it?
[SPEAKER_00]: How tall?
[SPEAKER_02]: It's only it's only dog sized.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you got dog shiesh and dog shiesh?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're very sort of German shepherdy style, kind of attack dog style types of dogs constructs, dog constructs basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you've moved 15 feet called it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Who I see behind it?
[SPEAKER_06]: Like what's in the alleyway?
[SPEAKER_02]: You have dark vision, right, as a Darkin?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can see down the dark alleyway tunnel behind it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't see anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you're pretty sure this didn't fire the shot.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's no gun that you can see or no reason to suspect this thing can fire a shot.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you've just stumbled into this, but it's not the shooter that you were looking for.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then I think I would want to try.
[SPEAKER_06]: So Larkki is not in this room.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I wonder if Felix would be looking towards my direction at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think he turned around to look at the shot the same as you guys did.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he's looking backwards towards you guys.
[SPEAKER_06]: Fuck it, I really want to try to get the... Nah, that gets me killed.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe I don't want to do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: Instead, I think my initial reaction would be extremely scared and then I scream a little bit and I shoot it with Chromatic Orb.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then run away.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, so yeah, do the chromatic off first.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I use this.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's a panic.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just shoot fireballs in all directions around you.
[SPEAKER_02]: None of them hitting the dog.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's so good.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I run away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you will take an interactive opportunity if you run, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, unless you want.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't forget to use the thing that you can use.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you can use.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you can use that on it being cast on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Not any time.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_02]: Because it says, yeah, it says each creature gains a temporary hit point and then can use its reaction to move up to its speed.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not like this is on you until that's why I think it's more for a combat thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But as far as I'm concerned, that makes sense.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you want to take an attack of opportunity.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have 15 feet more of movement that will get you to the central pillar or get you to the opposite end of the room or it'll get you back to where Lark is.
[SPEAKER_06]: I run behind Felix if I have enough movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: If not, then I run towards Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can get alongside Felix towards the center.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, you take an attack of opportunity.
[SPEAKER_00]: And if the North is colder, I will react.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Don't worry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's its attack?
[SPEAKER_02]: It is here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Make this public.
[SPEAKER_02]: Boom.
[SPEAKER_02]: Here only rolls a 12.
[SPEAKER_06]: Doesn't hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you watch these.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thanks to the mace armor.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That helps, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You watch this kind of conical head kind of snap at you with these pneumatic jaws, basically, that snap super loud.
[SPEAKER_02]: And kind of you will hear the crunch of metal on metal
[SPEAKER_02]: room as Calder kind of dives out of the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would have heard this, like you can't necessarily see into the tunnel what he's shooting at, but he throws fireballs in a panic and runs towards the center of the thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Felix.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will cast Healing Word on Harriet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Healing Word, Healing Healing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Healing Healing Word, Healing Healing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Apparently it's not doing anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Why isn't it doing anything?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, there we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now it is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So nine points of healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's kind of choking on blood as she's been shot in the neck, but she throws her hand up to her neck and it kind of heals some of the wound as your healing word goes into her.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she is able to like, kind of come back to consciousness, basically lying, still lying on the floor, just looking shocked and confused.
[SPEAKER_02]: And yeah, doesn't know what to do in this situation, but she is not bleeding out anymore.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else you're doing there, Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll try to gather up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, yeah, see.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we have, I think we have to go, Harriet.
[SPEAKER_02]: She goes, Felix, Felix, what?
[SPEAKER_02]: What is this?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just go, just go, just go.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she kind of like you pick her up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you can probably move half your movement after picking her up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can do 15 feet, which gets you sort of halfway across the room into the center of the room as well with her.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you're trying to drag her along with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'll do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then luck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I think, well, I would just yell like after Calder, like, no, don't go.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have to go Felix.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I run towards them because I don't want to leave them, but I want to run away.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I just run at them.
[SPEAKER_00]: And like, how can I help anyhow?
[SPEAKER_00]: Like I see Miss Harriet then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, they're both next to each other in the center of the room with Felix kind of holding Harriet under one arm as she is like covered in blood.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's got the journal in his other arm.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can get to them.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you run up to where Calder is, you will then see the howl in the tunnel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I do some action to figure out the best way to run to so we would get to a good alleyway or hideout?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can make a municipal check here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or as [a friend] calls it, gemeentecheck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Within 18, there's a number of tunnels.
[SPEAKER_02]: Essentially, if you want to get away from this howl, then heading to the northwest or the southwest, the opposite two corners, basically, you know that both those will run essentially to the same distance before you can get up onto the streets above if that's what you're trying to do.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we saw Harriet get shot even though we were like a bit further away as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I just assure everyone to move and I'm gonna place myself behind them and like move.
[SPEAKER_00]: If they're starting to move to the direction I'm pointing like let's go, let's go.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna be in between them and the howl in a protective state and I think I'll hold my action
[SPEAKER_00]: in case someone shoots or the howl attacks us and I well I mean that's already a reaction so I don't need to hold that um but if the howl runs to MLA I will attack it and holding my attack action for that yeah
[SPEAKER_02]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: From the darkness at the top of the thing here, a man is visible as he leans out over the barricade in the east corner of this room.
[SPEAKER_02]: He is going to shoot Felix, given that Felix is holding on to Harriet.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he has...
[SPEAKER_00]: If he hits, I will react.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's overcharging his Essence Carbine and he will shoot it at you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: I rolled that to myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: That was a 14.
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume that doesn't hit.
[SPEAKER_04]: It hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: It hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unfortunate, Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: 14.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: In which case he does this.
[SPEAKER_02]: Six points of damage plus another six points of force damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which Lark reacts to.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it should be 12 points.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's reduced by four by Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's down to eight points of damage to you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: What does that look like, Lark, as you are basically diving in front of bullets at this point?
[SPEAKER_00]: I point my hand towards the guy shooting and it creates like a
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a little invisible plate sized armour in there and when the bullet hits it, it like glows white.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, he has two attacks.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he shoots again, and obviously he has two attacks.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: The second one misses, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even despite his excellent positioning, he is not able to hit there.
[SPEAKER_02]: However, it is the howl's turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: The howl will easily make the distance to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It jumps forwards, giving you extra movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't need it, but it's cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it lands into melee with you, Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Your action is held so you can make an attack first as it jumps into action here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just checking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Inner radiance is the celestial stuff that I will need to decide to use, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think I have that as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: I attack the hull with my psionic strike as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Mm-hmm.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, 19 is going to hit, for sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to press the damage there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I will- Jesus fuck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jesus, what?
[SPEAKER_06]: Is that max damage?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, it's max.
[SPEAKER_00]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, almost.
[SPEAKER_02]: One point off max, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_00]: Holy.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I guess I will, of course, topple if I can.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it doesn't go down the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't go down, it looks fine actually after that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it?
[SPEAKER_02]: But you do manage to knock it prone onto the ground, so you swipe out its front two legs and it kind of crunches onto the ground and it's metal on stone as it collapses.
[SPEAKER_02]: Run!
[SPEAKER_02]: It's its turn next.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it just uses the rest of its movement because it didn't use all its movement to stand up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, and we'll, uh, bite you, uh, if it can.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, so just check this as public.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: 16 to hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Luck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Eight points of slashing damage and another one 23 to hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: 10 points of slashing damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll use one protective field on myself to reduce damage on one of those.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if I can decide or if it's just the latter or the first or however it works.
[SPEAKER_00]: Doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, it doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, technically you can't use two reactions in one turn, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, it's not been the start of your turn, so you haven't got your reaction back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, that's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, yes, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because even though the guy shot earlier, then I used my reaction on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, OK, good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good pointing now.
[SPEAKER_02]: Good call, good call.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's hope she doesn't die as a result.
[SPEAKER_02]: She just dies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So then that's the end of the house turn as it bites into the arc.
[SPEAKER_00]: How much damage does that take, sorry?
[SPEAKER_02]: 18 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: With that, you hear a growling coming from the northeast tunnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't hear a growling.
[SPEAKER_02]: These things don't growl.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hear a scraping of metal on metal.
[SPEAKER_02]: In fact, you hear the guy in the balcony above kind of whistle.
[SPEAKER_02]: And with this like shrill whistling noise, you hear a second howl basically coming down the tunnel towards you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It arrives at speed at the opposite side of the
[SPEAKER_02]: opposite side of the room, but it uses its movement to arrive.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is not in range yet, but it is also in the room at the edge of the tunnel, able to reach you next turn, no doubt.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the end of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Meanwhile, out on the balcony, back in the stacks, we will go back to the mid combat conversation.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, there we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're back again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Benjamin looks at you, Billy, as he takes you outside and says, Billy, what are you doing with him?
[SPEAKER_05]: Do you know who he is?
[SPEAKER_05]: I know his name, but Dad, listen, I'm in trouble.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm in big trouble and I need your help.
[SPEAKER_05]: You heard that Theodore was assassinated, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: I did, yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, me and a few others, including Asuka, we were there when it happened.
[SPEAKER_05]: And it looks like someone's trying to cover up that assassination.
[SPEAKER_05]: And us by being there, by association, we seem to be now kind of targeted by people from, I guess, Porter's Guild and maybe some others.
[SPEAKER_05]: And things are getting a little bit out of hand.
[SPEAKER_05]: Some people came and tried to attack one of my friends.
[SPEAKER_05]: We got out, but it's... Who is this we?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, yeah, like I said, some people that were there when Theo was murdered.
[SPEAKER_05]: We tried to help him, but it was too late.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, listen to me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, listen.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't get involved in this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to forget that you saw anything to do with it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to get rid of this Asuka.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to not associate with him and you need to get
[SPEAKER_02]: Back to your life as normal, nor any of this happened.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's right to get out of this, but it's following us.
[SPEAKER_05]: They've seen our faces and... Who?
[SPEAKER_05]: Who's seen your faces?
[SPEAKER_05]: Those people.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know who they are.
[SPEAKER_05]: What people?
[SPEAKER_05]: Who are you running from?
[SPEAKER_05]: The people that killed Theo and they're trying to cover it up.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know what they are.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's what we're trying to figure out together.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's why I need your help.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think we're all in danger.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just... You are very much in danger.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, you shouldn't be involved.
[SPEAKER_02]: The reason that you're supposed to be working at the scrapyard is to get out of trouble, to stay away from things like this.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't need to get yourself involved.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, whoever it is that's seen your face, I mean, have you...
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you done anything to bring about their wrath, so to speak?
[SPEAKER_02]: Have you committed any crimes?
[SPEAKER_05]: There were some...
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know what we call them, the guards that came to check on Theo when he died.
[SPEAKER_02]: Those are guild of engineers, guild of engineers, guardsmen basically.
[SPEAKER_05]: Some engineers, guilds, guardsmen, they saw me with the body of Theo and they might...
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know if they think I killed him or that they're trying to cover it up and now I'm a loose end.
[SPEAKER_02]: my friends are as well so I haven't done anything bad but I'm just you know associated with all that look these people the people that you're talking about here this is a dangerous thing to be to be associated with um you know this person that you brought into our home are is ask of a land
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I know his name.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, House Volan.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was touted to be the head of the Guild of Engineers when Dr. Tamerton passes on.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was kicked out.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's a wanted man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wanted?
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you mean?
[SPEAKER_02]: His family would very much like to see him, I wouldn't say killed necessarily, but at least removed from the equation.
[SPEAKER_02]: is a thorn in the engineer's sides, and if you're already wrapped up in any kind of engineer business here, this is just going to pull yourself even deeper.
[SPEAKER_05]: Look, I am not saying I fully trust that guy, but he has helped us get away with our lives.
[SPEAKER_05]: It could have been really bad for us if he hadn't helped us.
[SPEAKER_05]: I can't believe that he would be some kind of criminal or... What do you think he's helping you for?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's going to just use you as bait when the time arises and pawn you off to the Guild of Engineers as the culprits and no doubt... Look, look.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want to speak harshly about him, but just associating here with him is enough to put you on the radar.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you are already on the radar, it sounds like.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, the best thing you can do is turn yourself in.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I didn't do anything.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, then... To who?
[SPEAKER_02]: To the Guild of Engineers.
[SPEAKER_05]: And then I tell them what?
[SPEAKER_02]: That I killed Theo?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, you didn't kill Theo.
[SPEAKER_02]: You tell them that you were just there.
[SPEAKER_02]: You tell them the truth and you'll maybe you'll get in prison a couple of years.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the best you can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are risking your life.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm not going to prison.
[SPEAKER_02]: I didn't do anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, you know the situation here in the city and you know the power of the guilds.
[SPEAKER_02]: They do not care whether you did it or not, but they will remove you from the board one way or another.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, isn't there something else we can do?
[SPEAKER_05]: Like, surely you don't want me to really go to prison?
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't want you to die.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's what I don't want.
[SPEAKER_02]: If prison for a few years is the best solution to that, then that's the solution we have to take.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have no sway in the guild of engineers.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't believe you would say that.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would really tell me to just go to prison for years?
[SPEAKER_05]: It is the only choice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would you rather die?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't believe that's the only choice.
[SPEAKER_02]: There has to be something else I can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are messing with forces far beyond your control here.
[SPEAKER_02]: These people will not stop until they have dealt with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: And if you believe that they think that you have some information on a plot or ploy or... Let me tell you that the things that they are working on are far too precious for them to just...
[SPEAKER_02]: allow things to go wrong because of somebody being in the wrong place at the wrong time.
[SPEAKER_02]: How do you even know all this stuff?
[SPEAKER_05]: Are you in with them or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you part of that plot to assassinate the old man?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, no, I would never be part of a plot to assassinate anybody.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I have been working with the Guild of Engineers on a project.
[SPEAKER_02]: And so I know what they're like.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've worked with them for many years on and off.
[SPEAKER_02]: And this is not the type of place that you want to get involved with.
[SPEAKER_02]: Why are you still involved with them if they're so horrible?
[SPEAKER_03]: You can make an insight check.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I would like to use a Tides of Chaos.
[SPEAKER_05]: I shall click it into the chat.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the first time we've seen Billy not be a peasant.
[SPEAKER_05]: How do I do this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, nice.
[SPEAKER_05]: So that I get advantage on this d20.
[SPEAKER_05]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's a part of it.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got two 17s instead of just one.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's 34.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's how it works.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, with the 17, you say that to him and as you look at him, he stumbles for a second as if you are making a point.
[SPEAKER_01]: You say, why are you dealing with these people when they're so bad?
[SPEAKER_02]: And he catches him for a second, but he says,
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I wish I could explain more about what it is that I'm doing.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's important work.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is revolutionary.
[SPEAKER_02]: And look, I don't particularly like the guild, but they're the only ones who are in the position to really make these sort of things happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sometimes we have to just, we have to, you know, it's better the devil you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: know the phrase?
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't have devils in our world, so you wouldn't know that phrase.
[SPEAKER_02]: It doesn't make any sense in the context of the world, but if it did, you'd understand.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, he would say, you know, better velar you know, the god of evil, right?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, there are bad people throughout the city, but that doesn't mean that progress can't happen with or without them, and as much as I
[SPEAKER_02]: remiss to deal with the guild as I am forced to in order to if I didn't do this somebody else would and they may not have the same moral compass as I do I think I've raised you well enough to understand that we do what we can when we can we don't go out on a limb and get ourselves killed for no good reason I know so so then
[SPEAKER_05]: So what do we do now?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I... Aska is in here.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't want to tell him to go away.
[SPEAKER_05]: Can you just... You need to tell him to go.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, can't you do it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Billy, you're a grown man.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, yeah, barely.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't be solving problems for you, especially if you're in this situation now.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to take charge.
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to take the responsibility here and...
[SPEAKER_02]: You need to walk in there and tell him that you will not be associating with him anymore, that you know who he is and you know what he's planning, and you're going to turn yourself in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perhaps if you give them the information about Asuka, they might even be more lenient on you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perhaps you know where he's staying, you can give them some information for his arrest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perhaps you can even get off with just hard labor for a few months.
[SPEAKER_05]: If I do turn myself in, can you at least help me get...
[SPEAKER_05]: If I go to prison, maybe get a nice room or something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I'll see what I can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have sway over the guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: If it was the college imprisoning you, then sure, you would live a life of luxury.
[SPEAKER_02]: But look, I...
[SPEAKER_03]: But what if I go to prison and another accident happens?
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you mean another accident?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, like, you know, the floor in our house.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, they, and I suppose I shouldn't really mention this, but there are some people within the Guild of Engineers that can remove your ability.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can?
[SPEAKER_02]: Likely, if you were causing issue, they would
[SPEAKER_02]: look at that as a means of correcting your problems but look you know how I feel about that and I it's not something that I want for you well it would make my life a lot easier you haven't had any major problems for a while if I'm correct I know I haven't been around and I apologize but
[SPEAKER_05]: I have to live on my toes everywhere I go.
[SPEAKER_05]: I barely have a job because of what might happen if I lose control.
[SPEAKER_02]: There were people that would kill for the kind of power that you have, Billy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You have to understand that it's not just a curse, it's a gift.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's a gift that, of course, is dangerous, but is used in the right way.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think you just need time and a place where you can look, maybe prison would be good for you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe you can spend some time.
[SPEAKER_01]: that of the year.
[SPEAKER_01]: Hey, prison's gonna be good for you, son.
[SPEAKER_02]: But you run the risk, of course, of, I mean, I don't know how permanent these procedures could be, but that's not something that I would wish to happen.
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I can't tell you what to do here because I
[SPEAKER_02]: The only solution that I have for you is to give yourself up, and it's a harsh punishment for something that you haven't done, but it's the only thing I can suggest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Unless you have a way of clearing your name, a way of finding some proof.
[SPEAKER_02]: But look, I don't think they even believe you to be a murderer.
[SPEAKER_02]: I believe you to just be a difficulty to remove.
[SPEAKER_02]: But all of this aside, before you decide, you get rid of your association with this phalanx.
[SPEAKER_02]: Even if you solve your problems with the guild, the problems that House of Alanka cause you are just as bad.
[SPEAKER_05]: I mean, Dad, I trust you.
[SPEAKER_05]: If you think that that is what's best, I will do it.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll send him home right now, wherever home is for him.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's the only way that we can keep you safe, Billy.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'll just turn around and go inside towards Asuka.
[SPEAKER_02]: You walk into the room and Asuka is gone.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that makes things a lot easier.
[SPEAKER_02]: Back in the mellows.
[SPEAKER_02]: The plot thickens again.
[SPEAKER_01]: The plot thickens for the fifth time tonight.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's great.
[SPEAKER_01]: Back in the bellies.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many plots can we have?
[SPEAKER_02]: You put plots in your plots, so you can plot all your plots.
[SPEAKER_02]: Back in the bellies, then Colbert, it is your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are surrounded by... Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no, you're not surrounded by... You're running away from the things arriving.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, okay, yeah, you're not surrounded, but there is one hound in melee with Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are five feet behind Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: There is another hound 15 feet away from you in the tunnel, and there is a man with a gun on a balcony.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm constantly like, go, go, go, go, just go, go!
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, and I say to him, we cannot outrun dogs, and I shoot chromatic orb to the guy upstairs, hoping that this time it's not nat 1, but nat 20 would be nice.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like this.
[SPEAKER_06]: 19.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, that would have been so good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Almost.
[SPEAKER_01]: Holy shit.
[SPEAKER_01]: The cold shot would have been great.
[SPEAKER_02]: It still hits, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: That would have been great.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it's fire damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fire damage, cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you hear him kind of as he takes a hit and
[SPEAKER_02]: kind of ducks away a little bit away from the balcony as you hit them with these fireballs that come out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else for you?
[SPEAKER_06]: How far is the balcony?
[SPEAKER_02]: 15 feet and 10 feet up, so... Are you moving while you're doing this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Are you trying to get further away still or are you just standing still now because this is important for me?
[SPEAKER_06]: I think I would be standing behind you, so that you are between me and the hunt.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, yeah, yeah, but I'm trying, so you can just keep running.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I'm telling you.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I think I will stay behind you relatively close to the...
[SPEAKER_06]: Balcony still so I... Calder, what are you doing?
[SPEAKER_06]: That is my turn.
[SPEAKER_00]: Why are you staying, Calder?
[SPEAKER_06]: We cannot outrun dogs.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just move, Calder!
[SPEAKER_02]: Calder doesn't move.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, with Harriet under your arm, she's bleeding and you are...
[SPEAKER_02]: You're behind cauldron and lark with the hound on the other side, the howl on the other side, and one howl in the north corner from you as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I'm not strong enough to help it all the way, so.
[SPEAKER_01]: If it helps, she's telling you to get the fuck out of there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_02]: But now that you've picked her up, because she is healed, she's back to nine hit points.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now that you've picked her up off the ground and helped her, she can move herself on her turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't need to carry her any further.
[SPEAKER_02]: She will just run away, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: At the top of the round.
[SPEAKER_04]: Then I will cast Ray of Sickness on the guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: OK.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: What does he have to do for that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Let me check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, you rolled a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: No problem.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then yeah, 21 hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: 8 points of poison damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does it do anything else in that?
[SPEAKER_04]: And he's poisoned.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, he's poisoned.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, cool.
[SPEAKER_04]: And to the end of next turn.
[SPEAKER_04]: my next turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he takes another hit from, what does the ray of sickness look like from you, Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a bit like poison drops, but it's gray color.
[SPEAKER_02]: like a grey liquid, like a spray of grey liquid.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that hits him and he kind of like again pulls back, he's already behind cover, he gets hit by the second thing as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't tell exactly how injured he is from all that, but he's taken a couple of hits there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to move at all Felix?
[SPEAKER_02]: You want to move towards the exit?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure, because I am listening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, you have 30 feet of movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's 15 feet to the edge of the tunnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you could actually completely break line of sight and do a whole, use your full movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: You'll be 15 feet down the tunnel and away from the battle.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I'll be standing at the edge so they can still see me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: And don't leave them behind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you run to the edge of the thing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Log.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: She is panicking right now and the collar is not moving and dogs are coming and the guy's shooting.
[SPEAKER_00]: So she panics.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she's, her eyes start to glow, her freckles start to glow and her hair starts to like stand up a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is what happens.
[SPEAKER_00]: And what this means is that this is now active.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm just like letting you know.
[SPEAKER_00]: that Calder, you're starting to feel a little bit hot, possibly soon.
[SPEAKER_00]: And because she's trying to hold the line here and she just panics that like, we're all going to die if no one's moving here.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to hit the dock in front of me.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I use the bonus action to transform.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm going to hit with inner radians.
[SPEAKER_02]: Indie radius just happens at the end of each of your turns.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you can still do your action and it's just going to happen at the end of your turn anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'll just attack the doggy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, 19 hits.
[SPEAKER_03]: Six months of damage, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Untable.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it gets knocked down prone again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, sick.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you smash it back down to the ground as it jumps back up, bites you a bit, and then you smash it back down to the ground again.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yeah, you see Lark starts to also glow.
[SPEAKER_02]: And at the end of your turn then, each creature within 10 feet of you takes radiant damage equal to your proficiency bonus, which is three, I think.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or is it two?
[SPEAKER_00]: Two.
[SPEAKER_02]: Two.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Hal takes extra two damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's already counted.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, I've just rolled so bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: I rolled one plus three to the bloodshedning damage and the radiant damage is included already.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, but the radiant damage shouldn't be included on your attack because it's just anyone within 10 feet of you takes two damage basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't have to hit an attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: It always happens basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: In my effects like that I have to toggle it on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know why.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's the case.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Calder takes two damage as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the doggy.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the dog does as well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: The dog's looking a bit hurt.
[SPEAKER_02]: You knocked it down to the ground.
[SPEAKER_02]: You start to see a few sort of cracks on its shell as you're hitting it with the court staff.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is his turn, though.
[SPEAKER_02]: How is he looking?
[SPEAKER_02]: Hurt, poisoned, and he looks like he's not there anymore as he leaves.
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, he is much too hurt to continue fighting and he's in the perfect place to escape.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he leaves.
[SPEAKER_02]: But he leaves the dogs behind this dog on the ground here jumps back up with half of his movement and will attack you again.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it won't.
[SPEAKER_02]: It will use its nimble escape to disengage and it will run at you, Felix, still within its movement range.
[SPEAKER_02]: because it can do a 10 foot, with a 10 foot running start, the howl can long jump 25 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it uses half its movement to stand up, but it has enough, it has 10 feet and then jumps to Felix with its pounce, lands on you Felix and attempts to get you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It misses, but the second one hits and it does 13 points of slashing damage to you as it like basically like a dog, you know, grabs on the back of your ankle and starts like ripping at your,
[SPEAKER_02]: flesh as it tries to pull you down there as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: This howl is 15 feet away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cold is the closest target.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's just going to move 15 feet towards Colder and roll a natural one before rolling a 15.
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, 15 hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's going to do nine slashing damage to you as it also leaps up and starts to grab at you with its teeth.
[SPEAKER_03]: Colder.
[SPEAKER_03]: How is Lark and Phelis looking?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm looking pretty bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm hurt, but not like super bad.
[SPEAKER_06]: Because I'm thinking if I should go after the guy.
[SPEAKER_06]: I quickly ask, can you two handle this?
[SPEAKER_03]: Calder, we need to go!
[SPEAKER_06]: I take that as a yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: You didn't say if you can handle or no.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think what I would want to do is, because I'm still close enough the thingy over there, I would want to miss this step there.
[SPEAKER_01]: Bro is just get me the fuck out of here.
[SPEAKER_06]: Kind of following the guy over there.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then do I see him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Um, what's your darkvision?
[SPEAKER_02]: He moved 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: He moved 60 feet, so he's at the end of your darkvision, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I want to...
[SPEAKER_02]: He's just fading into darkness as he runs, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Cast... Do I want... Firebolt.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, wait, that's damage.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's damage?
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, that's natural ones.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's just in the darkness at the edge of your vision.
[SPEAKER_02]: You throw a fireball down the tunnel, it smashes into the side of the wall.
[SPEAKER_02]: You aren't able to hit him.
[SPEAKER_06]: Hey, guys, I'm leading the record for natural ones, by the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: You are.
[SPEAKER_06]: Right, catch up, guys.
[SPEAKER_04]: Catch up, Felix.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've also got one already this time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you can get another.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can catch up.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's your turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: So this hound that's attacking you is looking relatively hurt, the other one is still fresh.
[SPEAKER_03]: I will do Shocking Grasp on the one next to me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Unfortunately a 10 is not going to hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: [Krimson], what is the lady doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: She's just running.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's not a combatant.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's already passed Felix into the tunnel because she just used her full movement.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, she's so smart.
[SPEAKER_06]: But how the fuck do you think to outrun dogs?
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, she's just running.
[SPEAKER_06]: She's not thinking.
[SPEAKER_00]: She doesn't care, she's just running around.
[SPEAKER_00]: Maybe this person is a girl holding the dogs and the front line.
[SPEAKER_00]: So she has a chance to run.
[SPEAKER_04]: As a bonus action, I will cast a healing word on myself.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Country plus leveled spell works.
[SPEAKER_02]: Healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seven points of healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lock.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I get
[SPEAKER_00]: in range with the dog that ran to Felix without hurting Felix?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we don't have maps, so I've forgotten how to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just go behind the dog then, and I'm going to hit him.
[SPEAKER_02]: You will take another attack of opportunity from this dog if you do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said it went after Calder.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said he's closer to Calder, so you attacked Calder with the dog.
[SPEAKER_00]: So is he in melee with the both of us then?
[SPEAKER_02]: Uh, no, that's a good point.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's a good point.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, he's not in melee with you.
[SPEAKER_02]: He was in melee with Golda and not Golda misty stepped.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, that's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I go after the dog that went after Felix.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, oops, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's damage, luckily.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: 20 hits.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I guess, do we just count the above damage?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's fine for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, we can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Um, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_00]: And the plus two, I will topple it, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: You topple it.
[SPEAKER_02]: With the two, it is enough to take it out.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, you topple it, smash it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, never mind.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: You topple it, smash it to the ground, and then the kind of burst of radiant energy that comes out of you in Fury finishes it off, basically.
[SPEAKER_02]: It kind of like lays on the side, defeated.
[SPEAKER_02]: So one down.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I guess for Felix, it looks like there's something bursting out of me constantly, so it wouldn't look like you would want to come closer if you're smart.
[SPEAKER_00]: But yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is the other dog's turn.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nothing else for it to do but rush you, Lark, and attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: It will 21.
[SPEAKER_02]: 11 points of slashing damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: 19.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus, Crimson.
[SPEAKER_05]: Another 11 points of slashing damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: For fuck's sake.
[SPEAKER_00]: What row just rolled?
[SPEAKER_00]: Holy fuck.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I even survive this?
[SPEAKER_01]: If you, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know how much you can reduce.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, let's see.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will use Protective Field.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I don't think I can produce it anyway.
[SPEAKER_05]: Did you count your temporary hit points from the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes, but I have taken damage, unfortunately.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, you've taken quite a bit of damage.
[SPEAKER_00]: I go down either way from this attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: So yeah, the dog jumps on top of you and is basically just mauling at Lak's chest as she's trying to fight it off.
[SPEAKER_02]: She's down.
[SPEAKER_06]: Call it is the guy is the guy running, just running away.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah sorry yeah I skipped his turn but he is just running here he runs another 60 feet down the tunnel away from you.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Watch him running away, being a little bit pissed that I completely missed the shot over there.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I look back like how they are doing.
[SPEAKER_06]: I see one dog dead and then I see Lark on the ground as well.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm like, oh shit.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess I need to let that guy escape.
[SPEAKER_06]: And then I turn.
[SPEAKER_06]: This time surely Chromatic Orb hits, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: All the good rolls of our Crimson, we all know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, wait, wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: 13 hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: And fire damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice fire damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fireballs, hit them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, this other dog is not looking too bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is the first hit he's taken.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it's a decent chunk.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else, Calder?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_03]: No?
[SPEAKER_03]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_03]: Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: I walk up back to them and also do the Shocking Grasp on the dog.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now that I'm unconscious, I probably dropped my fee or the clash.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's kind of cool if it doesn't drop when you're unconscious, honestly.
[SPEAKER_02]: When until when is it supposed to last?
[SPEAKER_02]: 24 hits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Four points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You watch the four points of lightning damage seems to hit harder than you expect.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then as a bonus action I'll cast Healing Words on Lark.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think it's cooler if your inner radiance thing keeps going off when you're unconscious, obviously if you die it stops, but I think if you're still unconscious it's kind of just an energy that's pushing out of you.
[SPEAKER_05]: This is still her turn even though she's death rolling, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, I think and I just think it's cooler than it just kind of drops when you go unconscious, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's not it's not an active thing you're doing So yeah, five points of healing though, like you are back up One with a double one healing one healing one Unfortunately, but hey something is better than nothing Is that your turn Felix?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, it's cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So luck
[SPEAKER_00]: I get up or like conscious from the ground.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can I do like a really cool move that I see that Felix is right next to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I like put my hand on the ground and I like try to throw myself at the other side of the dog.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I would get further from Felix and just like be behind the dog, not leaving.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like, okay, I'm going to do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very cool.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's probably my moment anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: And
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll use my last energy dice to use psionic strike on this hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: If I hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, you can hit, sorry, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it takes.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's looking pretty good now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus 12, sorry.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, I didn't use a bonus action.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm going to use a second wind.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, let's go.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, it's a D10.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's still good.
[SPEAKER_02]: $11 is still really good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. Felix, how are you looking generally?
[SPEAKER_03]: Could be worse.
[SPEAKER_02]: And how about you, Lark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you think you could be worse?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm okay-ish.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm energized in this moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I think he's going to attack Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Actually, I shouldn't have even asked.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix is holding the ledger and it is clear that they want to get the person with the ledger at this point because the dog disengaged a charge at you.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you think that they are intending to stop Harriet or the ledger and therefore go for Felix in this case.
[SPEAKER_02]: So 20 for 11 points of damage and 14, which I think hits you, Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yup.
[SPEAKER_02]: 11 points of damage and 13 points of damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think he's dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix goes down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: The dog now jumps on you and the dog will pick the ledger up in his mouth.
[SPEAKER_02]: The dog will use its bonus action to disengage and then the dog will use its 40 feet of movement to run away down into the tunnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it uses 15, starts going down the tunnel for 20, so it's 25 meters down the tunnel.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool, there.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's looking kind of hurt, though, the dog.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, yeah, it looks very hurt, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I cannot do anything to help Felix, but I know that Buhuk is apparently worth killing for, so I will... Man, this fight burns all the spells.
[SPEAKER_06]: I just missed a step again.
[SPEAKER_06]: As far as I can, so it's 30 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's illegal.
[SPEAKER_02]: On a cool basis, you end up on the central pillar as you arrive.
[SPEAKER_02]: You turn up on the steam vent, steam ballooning around you as you arrive in the teleportation.
[SPEAKER_06]: As long as you don't make me roll any acrobatic rolls to get out of here.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's just like the most line of sight thing you can hear.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you just, boop, appear in the center, like a magician.
[SPEAKER_06]: Then I would want to run as much as I can and cast Ray of Frost.
[SPEAKER_06]: So it's slowing it down.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the range on Ray of Frost?
[SPEAKER_02]: 60 feet oh 60 feet so where you are right now you are within 60 feet you don't need to move but if you want yeah but i want to move i want to move sure so if you use your 30 feet you'll be 10 foot behind you'll be 10 feet behind the hound in the tunnel yeah i might regret this but yeah you can do it then you may have frosted uh what does what does that do what does it need to do i attack you make me attack cool yeah surely no more natural ones
[SPEAKER_03]: I click it, but nothing happens.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's a bit laggy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: Let's wait a little bit.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or I try it again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Tick.
[SPEAKER_02]: In the other campaign, the rules just stopped working one time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, seriously?
[SPEAKER_02]: We just had to play by people rolling physical dice for the rest of the session because [someone] was waiting.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, does this work?
[SPEAKER_01]: Should I just quickly test something to see if the rules work?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I tried to roll 1d20 and it says rolling the dice dot dot dot.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, god.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess it's lagging or whatever, but.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you have a dice with you, you can roll.
[SPEAKER_01]: I guess we need to...
[SPEAKER_01]: Wait, lemme...
[SPEAKER_06]: I do have!
[SPEAKER_01]: Alright... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 20... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21... 21
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll take the first one.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just know where you rolled through natural ones.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's crazy.
[SPEAKER_06]: Add those in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Add those to the stats.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't care if they don't count.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK, so with a 21, you do hit, though, with seven points of damage.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is not enough to kill the hound, but it is incredibly hurt with that.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it is also slowed, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Speed reduced by 10 feet, not technically.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else called it?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, I used bonus action, action, action, movement.
[SPEAKER_02]: Felix, you can whisper me a death saving throw, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: Lag.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what, guys.
[SPEAKER_00]: Guess what I am.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm a fighter and I forgot I have action search and I haven't used it because I'm a fucking idiot.
[SPEAKER_00]: Crimson, if I dash, could I get to the dog with my full movement?
[SPEAKER_02]: With a dash?
[SPEAKER_02]: 60 feet from where I am.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, with 60 feet you can get there, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I action search and I dash after the fucker.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna reach it!
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm gonna hit it!
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is, truly speaking, Lara is not this aggressive, she's just like, panicking.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Maan, you can do this.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nooo, fuck!
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh fuck, you're gonna fuck me up.
[SPEAKER_06]: But you're next to it.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can finish him off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ah, well, I use bone section.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait, it's a free action.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's a free action.
[SPEAKER_00]: Free action is action search.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, action, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_02]: Action search gives you another attack, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or another action.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_00]: I used it to dash.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, you use action to dash and then you have a bonus action if you've got anything to do with that.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, can you use your bonus action to dash and then use another action?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, only like rogues and people with feuts and stuff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Dash is normally an action unless you have a special.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it's like rogue and monks have dashes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll just use my second wind as my bonus action because I had one left here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jesus!
[SPEAKER_02]: That was hellish though.
[SPEAKER_02]: end of your turn your radiant light does two damage which is about to fucking nimble escape and then run away with 80 feet of movement but uh you kill it so um yeah with your last breath as you arrive in range of it
[SPEAKER_00]: I like missed the hit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I drop my radiant transformation immediately when it dies.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I would want immediately go Felix and try, I don't know, to do whatever I can to do.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can do a medicine check, Golde.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can make another death saving throw for me, Felix.
[SPEAKER_00]: Are we using the turn still?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, but in that amount of time, it's enough for Felix to have at least have made another one as you rush back the extra 10 feet or whatever.
[SPEAKER_02]: Kaldi, you can make a medicine check.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, I click it, but it's back along.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: OK. With a 19, you are able to stabilize Felix as he came very close to slipping away from this mortal coil.
Did you?
[SPEAKER_04]: I only wrote failures.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, but your second failure was a two.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if your second failure was a one instead of a two, you would have died.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, you would have died.
[SPEAKER_02]: You would have been fully dead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is kind of scary.
[SPEAKER_02]: But yes, you save him last second as he's bleeding out.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think Harriet kind of is looking back from the end of the tunnel and kind of walks back towards you as well as she sees this.
[SPEAKER_02]: And she says, I don't know if any more of them will come.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to go right now.
[SPEAKER_05]: I grab the letter and I go around to Felix.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So do you have any healing luck for him?
[SPEAKER_00]: I have healing for him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's stable, but if no one can heal him, you're gonna have to drag him out.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Healing cunt, healing, healing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: Cool.
[SPEAKER_02]: So for six points of health, you pull Felix back up to his feet with the healing hands, get him back on his feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: And three of you plus Harriet, you have the journal in your hand block as you guys rush off down the tunnel, hopefully to safety.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that's where we will end the session.
[SPEAKER_01]: I miss when we had a Barbarian who just tanked everything and then we just killed everyone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Logi still tanking everything but also getting down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Also getting down and then getting back up and then tanking more.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm so happy that the dog didn't hit me twice, because with those attacks, I would have gone down in one turn, like, what the heck?
[SPEAKER_01]: That's why you don't stay in melee, you stupid!
[SPEAKER_06]: But I remember Taviel teleporting next to some mob trying to stop me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think a dragon, I think Taviel teleported next to a dragon.
[SPEAKER_02]: And got hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just something that wizards love to do, go to melee.
[SPEAKER_00]: I had like three teleportation spells, at least with Tavil, so I could just get away if I needed.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, but you've got the insta-tab.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, geez, everyone, that was a nice mix of combat and sitcom energy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, that was so good.
[SPEAKER_01]: Also, where the hell is the egg now?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Where is Eska?
[SPEAKER_05]: Where is he gone?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Maybe my mom knows.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, GG's a good game.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, done.